Hey Dude.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Once upon a time we were in
Phoenix, Arizona. And uh,
there was like an open mic competition.
Was that what it was?
No, I think it was um, a contest
for the Las Vegas comedy. Yeah.
Festival.
Ah,
it was a Los Vegas comedy festival contest
and the one young man stood out and a
wound up working with us that weekend
and it's this Guy Josh McDermitt who was
on the fucking walking dead now.
Yeah, man. How's that
happen? I don't know man.
I was just talking to Brian about
it. Like I'm, I've hit the jackpot
dude. You got a lottery ticket. You
get the Willy Wonka golden ticket.
You're on like one of
the greatest shows ever.
It was my favorite show before I came in.
So literally like I hit the fan lottery
and I'm just like, I don't know man.
It's weird. It's really surreal to
think about like cause that show,
I don't know man w that show in Phoenix
that we did like you were doing a
weekend there and then,
then they asked the audience after your
show to stick around so that they could
do this little,
it was like a contest or some sort of
showcase to select someone to go to this
festival and they put me last and the
first comment goes up and half of your
crowd,
like most of your crowds stuck around.
Half the crowd walks after the first
comic and I was like, ah shit man.
And I'm sitting in the back next
to you and I hadn't met you.
I mean I met you like as I worked at
that radio station, but like you know,
we didn't know each other.
You're just eating your meal and you're
watching this and I'm looking at you and
you're not laughing at anybody because
it wasn't funny. And I was like,
oh this sucks man. Like Rogan's
just going to be like, man,
these guys fucking suck. Like he's going
to talk trash about us or whatever.
More and more people keep leaving too.
As the show's going on to,
to the point that's like a 500 seat
theater and there's like 30 people left by
the time I get up and I didn't
give a shit at that point.
And literally I heard you laughing the
loudest in the back am I sat and I'm like,
well that's a victory I guess.
And then I got to go to the festival
and that was fun and everything.
But like you literally, you
asked me, you're like, hey,
you know you want to open for
me the rest of the weekend.
And that just kind of set me on this
path to come to la and pursue acting and
the continue to do
standup and all that dude.
Like I don't know how much you realize,
like how important you've been to me, man.
Seriously. That's ridiculous. I wouldn't
be here. I literally wouldn't be here.
Wow. Well that's amazing because you're,
you're fucking fantastic on that show,
dude. So it was all meant
to be one of those things.
Yeah. I don't believe in fate,
but if I did believe in fate,
there's plenty of evidence.
There's plenty of evidence. Yeah.
And if there's a fucking bill Hicks,
bio pic dude,
you're playing,
you're not the first person to tell me
this is Craig Russell Crowe's got like
got the rights to some like bill story.
Yeah, well they'll probably ruin it. It's,
it's probably not something you want to
be involved with anyway. And it's like,
it seems like every time
they do a about a guy
that it was a real person, they just
butchered the reality and fuck with it.
What are they doing something with
Kinison awhile ago supposedly. Yeah,
I saw some trailer come out with some guy,
I don't remember who he is.
Like I recognize them from different
movies but like he was on stage just being
Sam and I was like, oh
my God, this is amazing.
But that was like five years ago and
I hadn't heard anything about that.
I haven't seen that. I never saw a train
know who it was. It was in that movie.
Take me home tonight with Topher grace.
He played one of the guy,
he like his friend in it, Dan, Josh Gad.
It wasn't John. He was a Josh Gad type,
says Josh Gad to play Queen.
A place names dude that walked
in and out because of projects.
Probably been on the shelf for so long.
They'll fuck it up
because they're doing that
prior movie too, aren't they
that up too? I think that already came
out. Yeah, the prior moon. No, no.
You're thinking of the Jimi Hendrix movie
that came out and that was dog shit.
They ruined them, man. I mean,
you know, there's this guy,
Mark Schultz and he was the
Olympic wrestler that, uh,
his brother Dave Schultz got
killed by that guide. John Dupont,
that crazy millionaire billionaire guy
in Connecticut. They fucked that up, man.
I went to see that movie
and you know, he was, he,
he's Mark Schultz made a bunch of tweets
about it. About how pissed off he was.
Yeah. About the, they fucked with his
story. They fucked with his timeline.
They fucked with how much success
he actually had as a wrestler.
Before he went to, he was
already an Olympic gold
medalist and a world champion.
They made it out like it
was struggling and sure,
they added a bunch of weird
gay shit. They, they, they,
they changed the timeline of when he
fought in the UFC and the UFC fought a
white guy instead of a black guy.
They changed the timeline of the UFC.
He made the UFC in 1987 didn't even
exist until 1993 like Hollywood is filled
with assholes,
just filled with assholes and
think that they can alter reality.
We talking about a real life story.
A guy's real fucking story.
Yeah. It's, they do seem to screw it
up a lot, but I don't really know.
Is there anyone that they've done that?
Has there been a movie that we kind
of go, oh yeah, that's pretty great.
You never, Lenny, Dustin
Hoffman Played Lenny Bruce and
he fucking nailed it. Yeah,
it was, and it was a really good movie.
Like, if you watch that movie, Lenny,
you really feel like, you
kind of understand what Lenny
Bruce was going through.
This is back when he was being tried
for censorship. He would, he would,
he would go in front of these courts and
they would make, they would do his act.
They would read his act out loud,
like the words that he said,
convict him for these, uh,
these profanity charges. I mean,
that guy really fucking paved the path.
If it wasn't for him,
you and I wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for the guys that like him and George
Carlin,
the guys that actually went to jail for
saying words that we say on a regular
basis. Right. If there's a 50
fucking years ago, it wasn't that
long ago. I know. It's crazy.
If you really stop and
think it's insanity, man.
Did you see that preview for the New
Light Nwa movie? That looks pretty legit.
I mean, it's a great trailer
documentary, isn't it? No,
no, no. It's uh, actually, uh,
it's just about them growing up. It
was a neat, yeah, it's kind of like,
and they have a guy that looks
kind of like ice cube and it,
I mean he sounds just like ice
cube. It's really neat. Who's in it?
A bunch of no names mostly.
But uh,
I guess that's why the whole thing
happened with the big guy. TMZ,
Josh McDermitt tweeting. Wally's on a
fucking podcast. Can't do it. Put it down.
I'm trying, I'm trying to find that guy.
Which guy here? Sam Kennison guy here.
He found it. You put the picture
up on the edge. Yeah. So isn't it?
Hold on.
How dare you,
you were making such a big deal
over there. There. Yeah. This,
what does the screen test? Dan
Fogler screen test. Tony winner.
Is that who the guy is? Well that's
a screen test. Hold on. Stop.
That's a screen test. That's
not a trailer. Yeah, I didn't,
I didn't know it was a screen
test when I watched it. It did.
I mean I would have known if it
said screen test, but wherever, uh,
yeah, I mean, yeah, I saw it.
That might not be him. I mean,
either way they'll ruin it probably,
but if they do a bill Hicks
one and they're going to
ruin it and give you a lot
of money, I say fine. I'd rather,
if we're going to ruin it, it,
I'd rather it be me ruining it.
Then someone else, you know, let's,
let's have some respect for the guy.
Do that character you play on the
walking dead. It's very unusual.
That's a weird character.
Like a strange sort of pseudo autistic,
really intelligent but fucked up
dude involved in like one of the,
like the shows not even about
the monsters anymore. No,
it's about the humans and their
interactions with each other and just them
surviving, you know, the,
um, the apocalypse. I mean,
the biggest threat isn't, yeah,
isn't the zombies, it's, you know,
the guy with the eye patch the governor
or it's like someone else going like,
yeah, you got food and water. I want
that. Yeah. That's what's really scary.
But this character,
you know,
it's kind of funny when I hear people
like really simplify him and go,
he's just weird. And I'm like,
okay, it's a lot more than that.
There's a lot more to him. He's
very complex and, um, you know,
it's fun to play a different character
on in this world where like, you know,
obviously you got guys like,
you know,
Daryl or Michaun who were just like epic
bad asses and obviously those people
are probably going to rise to
the top in this world, you know,
just people who are physically
fit and can just, you know,
do whatever they have to do to survive.
This guy is like completely opposite.
And that's what becomes fun about
playing him is that, you know,
you just wouldn't expect that.
I think I have a theory that if most be,
if the apocalypse happened,
most people would be more like Eugene.
They would like Daryl.
Yeah, most likely. Did you know
the, the whole character arc,
like what was going to
happen to him? Like, I mean,
I don't want to give away too much if
you're one of those that binge watches
stop now cause we're probably going
to talk too much about the show.
We'll fuck it up for you.
Spoiler alert.
I, um, well obviously the show
is based on a comic. So you know,
the information is out there from there.
But on the show they like to do it.
They'd like to deviate from
the story lines on the comics.
And how much did they deviate?
I mean they'll just create brand new
storylines for people. Um, again,
if you haven't watched this
last weekend's episode,
there was a major character death, but his
death, you know, he dies in the comics,
but the death and on the show was
not how they did it in the comics.
There was another character that,
that guy's death was this guy from
last weekend's death in the comics.
And it's show, it just gets
mixed around. Um, but with, uh,
so I knew that, you know,
when I took the job,
I knew that the big reveals
that my character would have,
and this is weird to be talking
about it in vague terms.
I feel like if you haven't seen it by now,
yeah, fuck you. If you haven't seen it.
It was, so we find out Eugene was lying
about knowing the cure. But the moment,
cause I came on in season four, I knew
that, um, he was lying the whole time.
Oh, okay. Um, but you know, I don't think
some of the other actors knew, you know,
because they don't read the comics.
They don't really tell us what's going
on with other people's storylines.
Right. And you don't know necessarily
whether they're going to stick with that
storyline that's in the comic or
whether they're going to deviate.
Right. And so that's where like, you know,
I knew that I was lying and that,
uh, once I, once that was revealed,
like all bets are off. Like I don't
know how much longer I have, you know,
how much longer be I'll be on the show
because they like to kill off their main
characters. So I'm just like, Oh shit.
All right. Hey man, this is going
to launch you, dude. I mean, you're,
you're on one of the best shows ever.
Dude is insane. It's epic. It's so good.
I watched last night and I was
squeezing my wife's hand while the show.
I've watched it. They didn't,
you know, this week's episode,
I didn't watch it until last night.
I'm just, cause she's like, Oh man,
like on my hand handling you get
fucking crazy. It's such a good show.
And it wasn't for a while.
It was really good in the beginning.
And then it was like a little dip where
I was like, oh, don't go Dexter on me.
You fucks. Don't, don't fail.
But then it pulled out like a
Phoenix rose from the ashes.
Even greater than before.
I know, man. It's, it's
insanity cause like,
so the guy who runs our show now,
Scott Gimble,
he and I don't really pay attention
to who writes episodes. Like I just,
I'm just like, oh, that's
my favorite episode,
but I'm not like looking up who wrote it.
So I started going back and looking at
my favorite episodes and I found out who
wrote it and it was Scott Gimple's.
So my favorite episodes from season three
was that episode clear where they're
in that dude's apartment and he's got
all the writing on the wall and like he's
gone absolutely crazy.
Do you remember this guy,
Scott Campbell wrote that episode?
I was like, oh this is awesome.
It's one of my favorite episodes.
And then the other favorite episode
of mine was, um, when Sophia,
the little girl came out of the barn and
she was a Zombie and they had to kill
her and it's like
he wrote that episode and I'm like,
okay.
So this guy running the show now has
written my favorite episodes all along and
it's like he's like the best guy to be
running the show because you're right.
I think, you know, it did kind of take
it down. It was still a good show,
but it's just like, it just kind
of like plateaued for a moment.
This is just me observing as a fan.
You know what it felt like.
It felt like a regular show. It's like,
it was so extraordinary in the beginning,
like the character arc between Rick and
his buddy who was banging his wife cause
they thought Rick was dead.
Like all that crazy shit.
It was so much nutty tension.
It's just like,
it left you in this weird space while
you're watching now where you didn't know
what to expect. And then the zombies were
new at that point. And it was, it was,
it was so much going on. It was like,
whoa. Every time the, the, you know,
it would fade the black at the end of the
episode, you'd be like, fuck, you know,
you just have to catch your breath.
And then it got to be like
a lazy Hollywood show. And
I was like, what happened?
Did some fuck head producer weasel his
way into a position of power and start
manipulating and shit and trying to
turn it into a number of the episode of
coach or something like that. Yeah. Just,
you know, administering Nelson shows up.
Like something happened like that.
Like it just became like a regular show.
I don't know the specifics, but
um, frank Darabont, you know,
Shawshank redemption is great.
Hollywood screen writer and director
develop the show from the comics and then
he, he was in charge of
it the first two seasons,
but then he left after the second season.
And so it's about the third season that
they kind of dip went over some rocky
terrain. Like, you know, they did
it. There was some great episodes.
It might be my favorite
episode is in season three,
but there they just didn't really hit.
It was very inconsistent.
And so then when Scott Gamble
took overseas and for it,
just took them right off right
off. It's amazing now. God Damn,
it's a good show. He's, you know, cause I
think just watching it as a fan, I would,
it would kind of get boring at
times where I'd be like, okay,
like they run out of supplies and
they're going to go on a run and oh,
it's not me. Pops out, kill it,
and then rinse, repeat, whatever.
So, but now they're like really developing
the characters and like bringing them,
you know, we're learning so
much more about them. It's
like fricking great. Well,
it's made, it makes me nervous. Every
time there's a new scene, it's like, it's,
it's so good right now.
Every time there's a new scene,
like literally entered into that
community where, uh, the, the,
the kid who played kick Chris rock grew
up in and as soon as you entered the
community, I'm like, Oh fuck yeah.
You know, like what's happening here?
Like you're fucking, Paul starts
racing, you start getting sweaty hands.
She like a little nonchalant about it.
Like they're just coming in,
just maybe checking around
and you're like, oh no,
you've gotta be looking everywhere
at this point. It's so good man.
And when he got bit like you
see just a shadow behind him,
just a brief shadow before it comes out.
It's like,
it's not enough that you, you know, you
see it clearly coming. It's like, oh fuck.
What does that, what does that, is that,
is that the kid that he's
with or is that someone else?
Who's The fucking shadow man?
Who's The fucking Chad?
The great thing about that bite was that
it happened like 20 minutes into the
episode as opposed to like,
sometimes they'll wait until
the very end. It's like,
oh no. And then they just, and then
the episode ends like he get bit,
he gets bit and then he has his,
you know,
hallucinogenic dreams and all
this about these, you know,
pass characters are coming back and
all this. I mean it was like a very,
Robert Kirkman, the guy who
created the comics was saying like,
it's going to be a fan favorite episode
is going to be a fan hated episode
because it's like,
it's a very poetic type of
episode that they wrote.
I really loved that dude too. I'm going
to miss him. He's nuts. He's so funny,
man. Is He, you got to get
a lot of here. He's like,
the funniest guy is very subtle and then
you just get them on a roll and he's
just like large and gregarious.
Like he mispronounces everything and
I don't know if he's doing it as a bit
like he goes,
there was some,
I guess he went to like University of
Virginia or something and there are some,
some school in Virginia in and they're
like doing away with sat scores are only
gonna focus on the GPA now. And then
he retweets it and puts it the front.
Oh hell yeah. My Alma Marta, Marta,
and may our DA. You don't know
if he's like kidding or not,
but like we were over at the table where
they keep all the food one day when we
were filming and he's just going to get,
yeah, go, oh, you see something you like?
He's like, yeah, I'm going
to eat me some beef jersey.
And I like, I just look at it. I
don't know. I don't laugh. I'm like,
is he just like dumb or is he doing this
on purpose? Like he's the funniest guy.
He's so funny. I'll hook it up,
I'll, I'll get, I'll get him in here.
He's great because he's off doing another
show now, I guess. Yeah, it's, I mean,
it's gotta be weird when you're on like
an amazing show and then all of a sudden
your debt, it ends, it ends for you.
And you sit back and you're watching
it as it's still on television.
You watched on the guys who worked with,
you know,
and occasionally they bring you back
for some dream sequence and you're,
and you're thinking, you know, it's
very cliche to say, but it's so real.
Like we're like, we're just a major,
like a big family there, you know,
cause we're in the woods in Georgia,
it's the worst time of year to be there.
It's hot and humid fighting off ticks
and bugs and use things called chiggers
that like burrow into your skin and
everything and then you're just out there
like with your friends
and family and it's great.
And all of a sudden now you die
and you can't come to work anymore.
He can't come to this horrible environment
anymore and you just want it so bad.
But um,
you know,
we'd go around and we do all these
like comic con conventions and stuff,
which is like, dad is trippy, but like
we get to hang out then and everything.
So you never really fully, you know,
disappear. That dude who was, um,
Rick's buddy, what was his
name? Shane. Shane, yeah.
That guy is in a lot of shit.
Like, he's in a lot of movies.
He's really good loan up. He's
really, do you see fury? No.
Fury was great. Um, I don't know
if it was based on a true story.
You're not the Brad Pitt tank movie, but
Jon Bernthal, that's the character, the,
the actor's name.
Phenomenal.
Like I was surprised he didn't
get nominated for an Oscar.
He was great in the wolf of
Wall Street too. Oh yeah.
Yeah, he's really good. He's,
he's like an ex boxer or something.
So like everything he ever does
is very physical. All this rolls,
he wants to just be, I mean he treats
it like he's in the boxing ring.
Didn't he get in trouble for beating
somebody up? Something happened.
Yeah, I think I'm lazy. He Lo,
he has pitbulls I think he rescues
pit bulls and then, you know,
lives in La and some douche
bag was complaining about
his pit bulls or whatever.
And then his pit bull started
getting a little feisty and angry.
And then I think, I think he just
popped him in the face. Oh, I rude.
Like a gentleman. I don't know. There's
probably stories about it online,
but I think the guy was just like, oh, bit
balls, whatever the fuck you, boom. Wow.
Like one of those things. But he's
a great guy. He's really cool.
Yeah. He's a really good
actor too. That the whole arc,
that story arc between him and
Rick was just suck. Oh Well Huh.
I've done just as many episodes as him
now granted like he was at the forefront
with like, you know, all his, uh, with,
with the storylines and stuff that
I've done just as many episodes,
but like he is just like at this
other level I can't ever compare with,
you know, what do you mean?
Well, he, I mean he's just like,
it was such an iconic character in
this huge storyline within that show.
So the first season was only six episodes
and then I did four episodes my first
season,
so like,
and then he dies to the next season
and I did just as many episodes as him.
Does that make sense?
Like sort of together.
We've done the same amount of episodes,
but he's just like at this other level
in terms of like how people remember him
and like the character and all that
classic scenario too, like coveting thy
neighbors wife, you know, that's like,
that's the big thing
with, with men. Like the,
one of the men's biggest fear is that
their best friend winds up fucking their
girlfriend. Yeah. I mean,
I mean that is a big,
or their wife or the mother
of their children, you know,
and becomes a father to their son.
You know? I mean there's, that's like,
and he wanted to take over and he
tried to kill him. I mean, that whole,
that whole thing was like so intense.
It's such a crazy dynamic in the kid.
The kid's amazing kids going
to to Shane for advice.
Like Rick's getting pissed and I mean,
it was awesome. It was, it was intense.
It was intense.
And it brought you in to this,
this changing dynamic of the
zombies not being the problem,
the people being the problem and how
the people react when they have to
formulate their own rules. You know,
I mean everybody that says like, uh,
like preppers, everybody says I'm
ready. You know, I got my fucking cans.
Like you ain't ready for Shit Dude.
Cause it ain't about that. It's, it's,
it's about how you react to all these
thinking animals that are trying to get
what you have now because
they're starving to death. Right.
Cause that's what the fuck happens
when the, if the apocalypse happened,
it's like if the big one hits,
you want to be right where it,
you want the earth to open up,
suck you in and close shut,
don't die of starvation.
Don't die because people are eating you.
Like in terminus you,
you want to, you know,
you don't want to be the guy who gets
baseball bat and then gets your fucking
throat cut into that.
The trough, you know,
you want to be the guy who the
meteor hits right on your face. Yeah.
The vein here,
that wipes out the power grid,
you want it to land right in your
head space. You know what I mean?
Really if you're going to go fuck, fuck,
going a year later or 10 years later.
Well, I mean, if you think about it,
I mean obviously my character was saying
that he had a cure and everything,
there's probably going to be no cure if
everything starts getting over run at
that point, they're not going to figure
out how to reverse it or how to fix it.
So yeah, you want to go first? Well, not
only that, not only is there no cure,
but everyone's infected.
Yeah.
That's what's the most fucked up thing
when you find out that everyone who dies
becomes a Zombie. Like when chain died
and they became a Zombie and you know,
like, okay, this is nuts. Like
there's no way out. Right?
Like you're your way out is gone, right?
Because everyone's a fucking Zombie.
So if you make a kid and the kid is just
born into your family and no one that
kid dies, it's a fucking Zombie.
Right? Everyone's a Zombie somehow.
Somehow has that. Does that ever
get explained? Don't tell me.
Um, no, I don't think there's, I
don't think they're just going to,
they don't have time to sit around and
figure that out. I think it was like,
we got to find a can of beans,
man. I gotta find some fish.
Wait, now guys, hold on.
We need to talk about this.
Yeah,
it's a w it's a weird
fucking weird scenario.
The idea of being the last
remaining survivors and like,
did you see the road, uh, who was, uh,
that was that very bleak post
apocalyptic movie with, uh,
the fuckers. That dude's name Veit
door. Morgenson what's his name? Vigo.
Vigo.
Morgenson like I did,
I watched it for five minutes until he
was teaching his son how to shoot himself
in the mouth. This is what you do, if you
know, if it's all over, you stick through.
Oh, it cut. We're good. I don't
need to see this shit. I just don't,
I just don't need to see this. I mean,
what am I going to get out of this?
I'm going to get, feel depressed.
There's not even any monsters.
At least the walking dead gives me
monsters. Yeah, right. Well, the thing,
the cool thing about the walking dead
too is they're always trying to maintain
some sort of humanity, some sort
of like, you know, civility. Yeah,
some rules and everything
and they're constantly, like,
even this last week's episode, they're
just like, yeah, I've given up, screw it.
Like I wanted to kill that person,
not because of what they did,
but just fuck them, you know? And you're
like, oh Geez, like it's all falling away.
And uh, that's kind of where the season's
going. It's just going to get crazier.
I wasn't a big fan of that hospital.
The CIC wearing makeup and all that.
I'm like, come on, get the fuck out
of here with all this. That was,
I thought that was a little ridiculous.
Like she's way too groomed.
She's on her fucking bicycle
every day working out.
Everyone's scared of her like that.
I didn't buy that at all.
I felt like that shit
would've lasted about an hour.
We're somebody punched her in the face,
took a gun and shot her in the head,
fucked her dead body, threw her off
the top of the roof. She's evil.
Get out of here. You fucking crazy.
Lipstick weren't [inaudible].
There's a few guys that didn't.
The guy with the eye patch get the fuck
out of here. That guy's a dead. He's dead.
He's not going to live.
You can't even see shit that's
coming from the right side, dude.
You're not going to survive. That is
not, you're not running anything. Okay.
I don't buy it always extra evil.
He doesn't even have superpowers.
Like how's that guy is going to
run? Shit. He's manipulative. How?
He's not even a manipulative. He's not
even demonstrably believe manipulative.
You know? It's like, what is
he doing? Just fucking, it's
weak. It's weak. Weak game.
It's got a week. Colt game. Dammit.
Stand on my left. I can't see you.
God Man. Yeah. There was like, you know,
there was a few bad guys in a few moments
that I just thought were ridiculous,
but it's the overall quality
of the show that just,
it keeps a,
keeps surprising you and he keeps drawing
you in and it just keeps making you
think like, what would you do if you
were stuck in that kind of a scenario?
Would you would just climb to the highest
building and just close your eyes and
fucking jump off? Like what would
you do? Yeah, I don't know. I would,
I would try and survive and
I would probably be one of
the first to go is what I
would do personally. I would
try, I'd be like, okay, I got it,
this and then I'd get bit like,
what about you exactly what I would do.
You don't even watch the show. And I
didn't sleep. No. I started watching it,
but I got to the season three and then
I stopped and I just haven't gone back.
But I've read the comics a lot,
most of them. Oh Wow. Uh, which, uh,
I enjoy in and looking at the
comics, there should be like, what,
11 or 12 seasons up to already written.
They got so many storylines.
It's not even,
it's a money machine. What? I mean, it's,
it makes so much money. It's so good.
One of the things is I
watch it on the, um, uh,
on Apple TV, which is the only way
to watch it. Watching it on AMC.
It's like you just want to fucking
drive to wherever the people are.
Who who put the commercials
in and go, Hey, fucking stop.
Fucking stop. Come on
man. This is not cool.
You got to Hardee's
commercial or a fucking,
you know Carl's Jr jammed in
the middle of murder and mayhem.
All of a sudden people are driving the
newest Toyota truck. We're having a party.
It's fucking so distracting
and so uncomfortable when
you realize that they're
shoving in 18 minutes of fucking
commercials in a one hour show.
That's obscene. Yeah, it's rough.
It's obscene. It really is obscene,
but when you watch it on Itunes,
it's fucking awesome because you get
the whole show, no interruptions.
Watch it. I tried watching it one time
and we paused and we just left the room.
We go.
It was just fucking come back in an hour
and fast forward through this bullshit.
Like we tried to just
watch the commercials for a
while and you realize like
what an, that shit is on
your attention span. I just,
it's an assault on your,
your, your reality. Like you,
why do you want me to dip in and
out of this world like that? Yeah.
It fucks up the whole
viewing aspect of the show.
Well I, I mean I want to
validate your opinion there,
but he's got to get paid
[inaudible] killed off next season.
I love the commercials.
Commercials are amazing.
I wish it was half an hour of the show.
Would you rather prefer like, like,
like commercials bill into the show?
Like they're driving a Toyota car
instead of having a Toyota commercial or
it would have to,
the only way it would have to be non
intrusive and there's no way that it would
work if it was not in.
She was like, you know,
if you see some people that are fucking
starving to death and they find a can of
coke and they drink it in
a Sharon it back and forth,
it's not going to make you want to
go out and buy a coke. You know,
you know that coke is fucking warm.
It's Georgia finding it in someone's
garage covered in fucking bodies.
Three years expired. Yeah. I
mean it's just, it wouldn't work.
And then when they do do that,
they do it like this.
Hey Man, do you think we're going to
get outta here? They're holding it.
I don't know
what this fucking good coke,
you know? I mean there's no
way that they had to do it.
Did y'all ever see like
the honest trailers,
the youtube channel where they do honest
trailers of movies and TV shows and
they did one for the walking dead
where they're just like, pick it apart.
It's hilarious.
But one of the things they were talking
about was like they were driving around
like a Hyundai Tucson for a
while and it was always like,
this is the apocalypse
or everything's filthy.
There's like a gross film on things.
And,
but the Hyundai Tucson
was like immaculate.
Like they're just cruising through the
woods and this thing and it, like I,
me personally, I never thought
about it. I was never like, oh,
I should go buy a Tucson or something.
But not until I saw that trailer.
I was like, oh, I guess I was
product placement. You know,
it had to be, if they're making
it clean. There was one episode,
I remember where we were talking
about it. We're like, why?
Why are these cars clean?
I mean even when it rains,
it doesn't really clean your
car. That could, you know,
I mean they have to fucking
have a torrential downpour
to do a half ass job of
cleaning your car.
Cause bird shit dirt.
It just kinda gets like moved
around on it. Right. You know?
Well people still have to find their
place in the apocalypse and maybe some
people are like, hey man,
I'm just here to wash cars.
We're alive. We got cars. Let's
Polish him up. Let me wash them.
Yeah.
I don't think that there's going to be
a ever a show like that that has product
placement as opposed to advertising.
But I think it's probably likely and other
shows and like, I mean, then you know,
they do that. And like when you watch
iron man, you see him driving an Audi,
Audi paid to get that fucking
car in the movie. I mean it's,
it's appropriate for him. It doesn't
stick out like a sore throat. I'm,
he's driving this cool car. He's a
rich dude. It all makes sense. But,
well you look at
something like madman too,
which is like centered on the world of,
but I think the catch
22 with that is like,
like they can't really do any
current, you know, advertising.
They're doing all like old, like lucky
strike cigarettes and this and that.
Then it's like, well I don't think those
are around anymore. Are they, you know,
are they around? But it's just, you know,
everything they do is like
from the 60s and whatnot.
So unless it's like General
Electric, which is so vague,
you know, it's still like,
people are like, yeah, that's right.
General Electric. I should go buy a stove.
I've never watched that show. Is that a
good show? Madman? It's good, but it's a,
it's a little slow. It's, I think it's
more geared towards women maybe. Uh,
cause it's very drama kind of.
It's not that guy ish.
Like I just watched it
because my girlfriend wanted
to watch it and that's the
only reason I watched it.
And I kind of got addicted to it and kind
of like an a Gilmore girls kind of way
where you're like, oh, I
know all of the characters.
So it's still fun to watch Gilmore girls.
I had to watch,
I've watched all the Gilmore girls
because of the girl I was dating and I got
into it. It was a great show. The girl
from the Gilmore girls years old man,
Lauren from the Gilmore girls. She was
on a season of a news radio. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I worked with it. She's
very cool. She's fun chick
mad men was a good show. I guess it's
coming back for their final season.
I did a couple episodes of that and like
it was kind of neat to like be in that
world and everything. But um, it was
one of those shows where like you,
you kind of hated a bunch of the
characters at first and then,
and you'd like some others.
And then like by season three,
that reverse the people you
liked and you're now hated.
And the people that liked and they kind
of went through these crazy evolutions.
You know, I think kind
of like any show, I mean,
it has its moments where you're like,
okay,
maybe I'll skip this episode is kind of
boring me or whatever. But um, you know,
for the most part it was pretty
interesting. The, um, the
girl, the very voluptuous, redheaded girl
that's like the big deal and that show,
oh, Christina Hendricks, see her
all who has body fat, you know,
but it's still sexy. She's a slut in
the show too. How dare she? Is She,
uh, yeah, I think she's a
little, a bit promiscuous a bit.
It's not slut shame. And the 50s,
Brian, she's awesome. She says she's,
she's a strong character though. She's a
strong woman, you know, but she, I mean,
they passed her around kind of.
Yeah.
It's gotta be strong carrying around all
that weight. Right? It's big burly. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Those breasts to Kohl's.
You gotta you gotta have some fucking
backbone. You seen her naked photos? No,
but I mean for, I think for women like
to have breasts that are that large.
It's probably really, I know it's, it's
really difficult on your back. I did,
a girl had a breast reduction because
their boobs are so big. She was born,
which is like with a really large breasts.
Her back always hurt and then she got
her breasts reduced and she was like,
it's like the world took a weight off our
shoulders. No. Think about it like that.
But if you have like double e tits,
I mean that's like,
those are fucking probably like 20 pounds
or something around a lot of God damn
meat.
That's a lot.
I saw her in person at a table reading
to her boobs weren't as big as they
appear to be on TV or
in pictures and stuff.
So I think she just kind of
looked like a normal person,
but they just made me push them up
a bit. You know what I mean? Oh,
well maybe they CGI or spread around,
but I've seen her in like photos. She
looks a very voluptuous but sexy. Like,
she doesn't look very sad. She doesn't
look like, listen bitch, you know,
you gotta get off that fucking
craft service table. Right.
It doesn't look like that. She looked
like a normal healthy curvy girl. Yeah.
She just looks normal in real life.
But you know about this tricks bodies
could probably imagine if you're here,
listen to this.
I love how that,
that she's like the number one
Photoshop to girl on the Internet.
There's like thousands of photos.
There's so many fans that are in love
with her boobs. So they overdo it. Yeah,
but you're showing a porn dummy. Huh?
There's porn there. Oh yeah. But I mean,
I'm talking about, don't know, I'm
just showing it to you. Okay. Yeah.
I'm just showing it to you.
But she was,
she was a part of the faculty or
the f whatever it was called. Yeah.
Were people uh,
stole when they got the,
the cloud photos people and
their goddamn cloud phone.
So she had a lot of naked ones. I think
she had three, if I remember her. Yeah,
let it shine. Girl. That shit.
The those shows about alternative
times are always odd to, you know,
those shows that they're doing,
like from the 1950s of the
1960s the period piece shows
are always very strange.
I think he got to have someone who's like
autistic running that show, you know,
someone who just like can consume all
the knowledge from within that time,
that era. So they can just like,
you know, do that cause for me,
if I were like writing on a show that
took place in the 60s I would be putting
in and then he grabbed his iPhone. It
like, I wouldn't be thinking, I'm like,
Oh God, we're in the 60s
if you just need like this,
this super nerd who just knows
everything about the 60s and that's it.
Well that's what we were talking about.
What that movie Fox catcher
that they fuck with timelines.
Like when you're doing
something that's historical,
it's very important that you stick
to the timeline because otherwise,
why are you even doing an
historical movie? Right?
Just did do a movie that's
completely fictional,
that's like influenced by
or inspired by a true story.
And you're trying to do an
actual real story though. Yeah.
That whole story was messed
up though. I mean the, the,
the true actual story of the Fox catcher
thing. I mean, beyond good grief.
I, and Mark Rufallo was great and
it hazing and then, um, and I,
even Steve Carell, Steve
Carell was awesome and it
seemed like the same guy. No,
not at all. And he played
that, that role so perfect.
The role of this eccentric,
nutty,
like really fucked up
cokehead multimillionaire,
billionaire or whatever it
was that he played it so well.
Like you really believe that he was
this guy with no character that had been
handed everything to him in his life
and he just didn't understand. Yeah,
that was a good movie. And
Channing Tatum, I mean,
I'm not like the biggest fan of because
cause don't like him cause my wife likes
it. Mensa, she thinks he's good looking
and she wishes I had his body. But um,
no, he, you know, I don't know. I'm just
not like Magic Mike. I just was like,
it wasn't your favorite movie.
No, but they were naked and
dancing. I don't get it.
I don't understand you. But he was great
in Foxcatcher. He was really good. He was,
he was just walking around. It
looked like a giant ape. Yeah.
He stuck his lower jaw because that's
what like when you look at Mark Schultz in
real life, he has this very prominent,
you know, fucking ape like jaw. Oh Wow.
Mark Schultz was a beast.
Dude.
He was really weird the way they did
the movie because they could have easily
had him fight the guy that he
fought in the UFC in the movie.
But instead they made up some
guy made him fight a white guy.
It was really weird. He fought, he fought
Gary Goodrich. It happened in 1996.
It's a fucking historical fact,
but in this stupid fucking movie,
it was a different guy. And uh, the,
the UFC took place,
like when he was watching it on
television was in like 87 or 88. Yeah.
They fucked with everything in that movie.
So they fucked with his accomplishments.
Like when he went to it,
the Foxcatcher farms or whatever
the, the, the guy called it,
he was already a world
champion multiple times.
He was one of the best wrestlers on
earth and they made it look like he was
living in his brother's shadow. Like she
wasn't, you know, it's just not true.
When they did that,
just to add drama to the storyline,
like this guy needed his brother there
in order to rise to occasionally.
He's the big dumb Ayp and his brother
is really intelligent and a really good
wrestler. I was brother was really good,
but he was really good too. You know,
and then they just, they always do that.
They'll do it with the Kennison movie.
They'll do what the Hicks movie get.
Trying to spin it a little bit to give,
you know,
for some dramatic effect or whatever.
But you can't say that it's
a true story at that point,
but you don't have to spin it when
the story is so fucking crazy. I mean,
Steve Carell's character,
that Guy John Dupont was in real life to
the things he did were so fucked up and
so crazy. Yeah. I mean, he really
did shoot Mark Schultz, Mark Shields,
brother Dave in front of his family.
He fucking pulled out a gun and shot
him in a cocaine psychosis. Yeah.
And that was real. You know,
so it's, you don't have to,
you don't have to monkey
with that man. Right. Weird
enough. But maybe, I mean, I'm,
I'm not like justifying it,
but maybe when there's just millions and
millions and millions of dollars on the
line and will start overthinking it.
There's too many cooks
in the kitchen and Nah,
we gotta have him fight a
white guy. We can't, you know.
Yeah. They change it. True.
That is true. That's not to say it's
okay. It's just good grief. They,
but it's weird to do it while the guy's
still alive and, and young. I mean,
he's not even, I don't even
think he's 50 he's, you know,
he's alive and well and they're doing a
story on his life and they're changing
everything around monkey in
reality. That's just crazy. Yeah.
It's just something that just happens.
There's so much money involved
in Hollywood. It's just
why when, when a show like,
like game of Thrones, when a show
like that comes off, it's almost like,
like how did this happen?
Like how did they make such a perfect
show in spite of all the madness that's
involved in Hollywood?
Like how did they figure out
how to do something sold good.
I don't know. I mean look at,
even recently I was reading
a thing about all these,
like that movie Jupiter ascending,
another dog piling Channing Tatum today.
But um, it just became, uh,
it just came out and it was something
like 80 or $100 million. I Dunno if,
if we know the actual budget and it's
like it's opening weekend made like 10
million. And it's like, why are
you spending that much money?
Like what was it, ah, some Scifi
movie. I don't know if it was,
what if he was based on something? It
probably was since everything is nowadays,
but you know to,
for something to cost that much.
I mean that raises the
expectations so much.
But it's probably because everyone's
going, we got all this money invested,
we've got to fuck with this, we got to
do this and change that and you know,
whatever, whatever. So it's
kind of sad that then, you know,
you get a small thing, don't, I don't
want to say game of Thrones is small,
but it's like, you know, how is
it that that's, like you said,
it's able to be something so perfect,
be something of a high
quality. It's, it can be done,
but they just fuck with it too much.
Well, I think game of Thrones is
also HBO and Hbo seems to be, I mean,
it's just from an outside perspective,
I'm never worked for them.
They just seem smarter. They seem
smarter with their choices. I mean,
they put on the soprano's back when there
was nothing like that. Yeah. You know,
the, their choices have been like,
they very rarely have a dud on HBO.
And I'm like, when was the
last dud show that HBO put out?
I don't know.
Yeah.
See it's like you can think of a
million shitbag sitcoms and NBC fucking
diarrhea it out onto America.
Right. You know, you can literally,
you could just sit down with a pen and
paper and write down how many CBS shows
made you want it to open up
a fucking vain. You know,
like if somebody made you watch,
you know,
Mike and Molly every day for the rest
of your life or jump off a bridge like
you'd have to go. All right. How many,
how long has an episode? It's 30 minutes.
All right, I'll watch it. Billy
Gardell is funny though. He is funny.
He's a great guy. Well, the girl is funny
too, but it's, it's one of those shows,
it's like they make these
mass produced white bread,
mayonnaise,
sandwich shows.
Well, and they're doing 26
episodes, so five seasons into it.
That's well over a hundred episodes
that they've done. It's like,
wha what more do we need to
see out of these characters?
When you look at game of Thrones though,
what, what season are we about to start?
Season four or five and they've
only done 10 episodes a season.
Right. So it's so epic though. They
have so many CGI things and the theory,
it's a great show from top to bottom.
It's a,
you must be an insanely expensive
show to make it like that.
The war with the fucking giants and
they're the fucking Rashad giant arrows at
these things that are coming through
the walls and chasing people and areas.
Shit, man. Oh Man. It's such a
God damn good show. But like,
it's interesting like a show like, like
a Mike and Molly, like Billy Gardell,
who's a very funny standup comic and a
great guy. Nobody knows who he is, right?
But everyone knows who that
Melissa McCarthy girl is.
She's on the cover of
fucking rolling stone.
She's in every other Sandra Bullock
movie. You know, it's, it's,
it's weird how that happens.
Like one character from one of those shows
will take off and the other one is a,
oh, that's that chick's husband.
Yeah. You know, it is weird.
It's Hollywood. I mean,
how do you explain it?
How do you explain it? Josh?
Mcdermitt you're in Hollywood.
I don't know. I don't know
man. Don't put me on the spot
being an INS Hollywood insider too.
Like do you get like what did you get
people that are coming up to you now
because you're on the walking dead
and go, hey man, I got this script.
I mean if you could just get
it to those guys or respect.
Yeah, to a point. I mean I get a,
I get hit up for things a lot.
Like I, I was telling Brian,
I was doing a show tonight and I
haven't done standup in a while.
It's been a long time,
but the reason I agreed to do this
show is cause he's like, dude,
I'm not going to promote you. I'm not
going to say you're on the show. Whatever,
you know, I won't put you on the flyer.
I was like cool, low expectations,
but I'm getting hit up to
do shows with these guys.
They want to make me the headliner.
They want me to,
they want to use me to promote
their show. I get it. But like I,
I'm going to go up there and shit the bed,
if you put me at the headline,
I haven't performed in a year.
Yeah,
he has gone up for a year and you don't
miss it that you didn't miss it at all.
He said miss it. Does that scare
you? But I mean were you like,
I mean cause comedy was your thing
before this that yeah, I mean it,
it scares me a little bit but I mean
I just was getting so burned out on it
about doing standup in La and like I would
go on the road and I would love being
on the road and you get to do a real
show and you get to work on new material
and you get to like, you know, have
fun and then you come back to la.
And I was just like
wanting to kill myself.
Why shows I hated doing standup in La.
I don't know what it was.
I would never have a good show. I could
never work on new material. I, you know,
honestly what I would do, the ice
house shows, those were like the,
the best of the shows that I would do.
But then I'm like, you know, I live,
I live on one side of the town and
it's the shows on the other items.
Like on a Friday night, I get to drive
out there, but you know, it just,
and it wasn't what I wanted to be doing.
Ultimately I want to be acting.
So I just,
so when you kind of got into stand to act
or once you started acting, you realize
you liked it. But a little of both.
I think, you know, I, I loved
doing stand up, you know,
I did it for 12 years and then I was like,
you know,
but I do want to eventually be acting,
you know? So it wasn't like, oh,
I'm going to use this to get in the door.
It was just like,
I'm going to do stand up
and I also want to act.
But then when I started kind of
dislike, stand up, at least in La,
I started love acting more. What's
your, what was your, with standup in La,
like you said you can't do new material.
Like what do you worry about?
People are watching and they're
worried that you're gonna fuck up.
No, it was like a weird, um,
I don't know. I would like,
I would just do a show and
I'd run new material. I mean,
I don't know what your success rate is.
I mean,
you've been doing standup
for what, 26 years, 26 years.
So I don't know what your success
rate is on a new bit that you, right.
If you're going up and it's like,
let's say you're going to try
out 10 new minutes, you know,
to seven minutes of it usually work or
does three minutes of it usually work off
the bat?
Like what is
completely varies.
I mean,
one week it can be one minute and the
next week it could be all 10 week to week.
It varies, uh, topic to
topic. It varies. It to me,
it's all about how inspired I
am by what I'm talking about.
And if I'm very inspired,
then I'll find what the energy is in
whatever the subject is and if I'm not
inspired. But I know what
you're saying about there's,
there's a sort of over it that the
Hollywood crowds have la celebrity.
Well they want to see Louis C K or
if there was fraud, they're over it.
They're over it. They've seen a
million of them before. They're not,
they don't laugh as much.
I mean I've seen like at the comedy store,
literally a whole table full of people.
Like you know,
especially if you're watching the back
that are just sitting there like this
with their arms crossed, like a whole
table full, like not having fun,
not enthusiastic,
but you go to Pasadena,
which is only half hour away
and everybody's having a
great time to go to Irvine.
It's only 40 minutes away. Everybody's
having a great time. It's just this,
this one center, the La Center, the TMZ,
the 30 miles. Oh, it's
also like these people,
a good percentage of them want to be
in show business themselves. Yeah.
And people like this fucking friend who's
an actor and it's impossible to watch
movies with this fuck. Because he was
like, oh, whatever happened to that guy,
his career like Jesus Christ,
can you watch the fucking movie man?
What about your career shithead?
Yeah. You know, you're,
you don't even have a fucking career and
you're shitting on this guy who was in
Jurassic Park to stop, you
know, you can't, they're,
they're so self obsessed that they can't
even just enjoy a show and joy a movie.
Right. You know, it has to be
something about careers or you know,
the arc of their life's history.
I mean, it can't just be,
it comes a human nature thing that we
want to like pick apart other people in
their successes.
But it's like heightened when you're in
Los Angeles and you're just constantly
bombarded with people doing what you're
setting out to do and maybe, you know,
you're reminded of your failures
and that sort of thing. I mean,
it could be that too.
Oh for sure. I mean they look at you and
like, she got fucking lucky on that show.
Dude.
I could have done that.
What do you do when you're playing a
fucking weird guy? Yeah, I could do that.
Yeah, Bro. If I was there, I fucking,
I guess what if I was in the fucking
audition room before you do it,
I probably would have got that. So fuck
off now you hear that. I take your order.
You hear that? Well you
definitely do. You, you know,
you get definitely get people that
for some reason resent you for,
you know,
going to the audition,
getting on the show and they're
watching you on television.
They've seen you in real
life and they're like, man,
that had been the perfect show for
me. Yeah. For the most part though,
the fans have been great, but
there are those guys, those,
those people just like at least centered
in Los Angeles where you're just like,
you know,
you're,
you encounter them and they are completely
negative and I could have done that,
you know, whatever, whatever. But you
know, when I say I didn't miss it,
it's not that, you know, it's not
like I was just sitting on my couch.
I was doing something really fun.
Right. You know, so I was like,
it's not like I had this thing
talking to me. I had like a,
an open invitation to go do the clubs in
Atlanta when I was living there. And um,
I just never was able to make it. I was
exhausted all the time. Yeah. When you,
what are the long hours like you do,
you guys are working on set? I mean I'm,
I'm usually up like at three 30 in the
morning and half an hour south to um,
where we shoot you because we live in
Atlanta, but we shoot an hour south.
I mean I could live down where we shoot,
but there's like literally nothing to
do. I would go crazy. So, you know,
I just do a quick little drive
back up to Atlanta. But uh,
so you're up at three 30 in the
[inaudible] 30 in the morning,
get down their father. Yeah. I'm one
of the first guys on set cause I got,
they got to put my mullet in,
you know,
literally they need time
to put the mullet man.
If I just grow out a mullet for real,
I fucking save a lot of,
I don't want to have a social life,
but that mullet out and
people would be like,
I know I throw a hat on
and then that no one knows.
But if I walk around with that guy who
plays Abraham might cutlets and he's got
that handlebar mustache,
like he can't get away from it at all.
I can put a hat on. No one knows. But he,
he can't get away from that
mustache orange, you know.
Does he have to wear that mustache
all year round? Yeah. Oh yeah.
So right now he's grown it out like
in a beard. So when you get to, like,
when you get to the end of the season,
how much time do you
guys have between the,
you're wrapped for the season and
how much downtime do you have? Well,
we wrapped in Nov, uh, like right the
week before thanksgiving, so November.
And then, um, the show doesn't
come back until late April.
And so do you have like a contract
clause? Like, you can't gain weight,
you can't shave your head. You can't,
yeah. There's some stuff. I mean I think,
I don't know specifically those sorts of
things I think is just how common sense.
Right? Yeah. Don't gain weight. Don't
lose weight, don't cut your hair.
You don't get crazy. This is a show
looking for people to kill off.
I don't want to give them a
reason like come back and um,
I looked like Chris Pratt,
I'm ripped.
All of a sudden they're like on and that
they would probably work that in this
storyline. Maybe you could be dancing.
I would. Magic Mike's style. Yeah,
I would. I mean I, I find a believable,
if someone's going to lose weight, like,
I don't know if you've watched lost, but
that Guy Hurley never lost weight gained
weight actually. Well it's cause he got
money and he started eating good. Yeah.
That's what happened. Was, is, you know,
it's like they're on a desert island.
Like your, you would lose weight
a lot. A lot fucking way. Yeah.
You're just eating pineapple all the time
or whatever. Like just lose the weight.
There's no gluten on an island,
right?
Every island is gluten free.
Cookies a bring your own gluten
or you get none. That guy like,
it's sad when you see a guy like that
because you know like that guy's so
typecast and so,
so morbidly obese.
It's like you,
you were on a huge show,
last giant show and then nothing,
nothing.
Why him and the Asian guy who's
on both on that show, it's weird.
It's like lost,
but now they're cops like recurring.
So they probably kept him in a while like,
look,
you're in Hawaii already and you
want to work here. Yeah, exactly.
Because I saw him,
he in Burbank the other day and I think
it was on a date or something like that.
And he, he's the girl is with like
literally came up to his belt.
It was just this little small girl
and he's this huge big Joey Diaz guy.
He's way bigger than Jody is.
Weighed like twice his size.
Ralphie may style more than joy. God, how
tall is he? Is he a tall guy? He's tall.
Taller than me. I was way
taller than I thought. He was.
Wonder how much he weighs?
500 pounds, whatever you think.
500 it's a big boy. 400 at least.
Joey got to like four 50 good. You know
the, when Joey was at his largest, he was,
you know, people get big.
It's a lot of God damn weight.
I used to weight 300 did
you realize holy shit.
And then I went down to two 20
I mean I dropped like 80 pounds.
What did you doing? Just,
you know what, it's,
it's this fad thing called eating right
and exercising people should try it.
But you know what,
I got a problem with eating Mexican food
and overeating and all that stuff. So,
and then just being lazy. So
then I yo Yo, I get back up to,
to 60 and then I go to two 40 and I'm
just all over the place, you know?
But my dad's a huge guy and
I got big guys in my family.
I'm just afraid that I'm kind of in a
sense predisposed disposition to do that
unless I work my ass off. Yeah.
Jeans or a motherfucker, dude,
you see some people like you see their
kids are kids are three and they have
these gigantic Michelin tire
arms and you're like fuck.
I mean a lot of it has to be diet,
but it's very clear that some people
can eat anything they fucking want and
never gain any weight at all.
Well they show these kids on Maury
Povich where like he's like trying to
confront the parents.
So these obese children and then they
just like have the kid in the green room
and they're just,
they set a camera on them and there's
this giant bowl of Cheetos and the kid's
two years old and he weighs 80 pounds
and he's just like wolfing down Cheetos
and it's like, that's like every day
for them. That shit is so bad for you.
Most of the American snacks that you buy,
like most like Cheetos and
Doritos and all that stuff,
it's just if they're filled
with hydrogenated oils
and fucking fats that your
body has a really hard time
digesting and artificial colors.
Your body's like,
what the fuck is the diarrhea?
Your body just has no idea what to do
with it all. But sometimes it's so good,
dude. Spicy Doritos. Oh
Dude, forget about it.
Especially if you're high,
you're high and you just,
you're hungry and you open the cabinet
and there, there you go. Yes. Yeah.
You don't even think you just cook. Give
it to me. I never, I never buy that stuff.
But if I see it out, like if, if
there was a bag of Doritos here,
I'd eat the whole thing. The craft service
table at the walking dead worst man.
Do you have a craft service table out in
the sun? Like how does that work? Yeah,
it's um, they just, well they
put a tent over it, but yeah,
they just have and you can order
anything you want. You can say,
give me a grilled cheese sandwich or a
case study or they'll go make it for you.
And so I always try to have someone
else order for me so that they order
something healthy. Uh, otherwise
I'm ordering, you know,
chicken case ideas and then I
ordered something else. But, um,
so then of course like the actor thing
is to get like Turkey wrapped in lettuce.
That's the avocado. All
the actors eat that. Yeah,
that's hilarious. They try to
pretend they're eating healthy.
I am healthy. I'm not
like you, I'm so superior.
I have all these healthy fats,
Omega threes bro.
I graze though.
That's a problem I always had with
the fucking craft service tables.
I would just graze and
it'd be upset at myself.
Like why did I just eat ADM and m's?
Cause that's what they,
that's what they put out. They're there
and you're just like, you get a handful,
you're like, all right. You'd like justify
them. It's going to have a handful.
Then you're like, oh shit, I got another
hand. So you scoop out some more.
You know it's, I have, I have the
biggest problem with all that stuff.
Kevin James brought a fucking
trailer on his, uh, when he,
one of his movies and the
trailer, it was like, you know,
like a regular big moving trailer and it
was filled with exercise equipment. Oh,
I thought you were going to say
just how close it ring
dings fucking doughnut.
They do that like the rock does that
he's got a whole trailer or will Smith
might have like a big bus
full. Yeah, that's great.
Well I think that's
where Kevin got it from.
I think he got it from will Smith when
he did that movie with Will Smith and he
was pretty inspired by that guy.
But um,
I think that's a common thing.
They have these trailers that they
rent and you get in them and they have
everything and they had a tanning booth
in it too. Oh my God. That's over the top.
You can go lie down and get
a Tan, but you can, you know,
you could get like a full workout
in right there on the set.
So like he was doing that.
Here comes the boom movie where
he had to play a fighter. Oh yeah.
He lost a shit load of weight,
gained it way back, like double time.
I just saw the preview for that.
For some reason they made a sequel to
Paul Black or the male mall cop sequel.
You know, holy cow, he's big.
He got big, he got a big,
I mean, why did he lose weight? Was it
because of, uh, gained the weight back?
Was it because of habits or is it because
maybe he thought he's not that funny
if he's skinny or like,
you
know what I mean? Like that's the
kind of mentality that people have,
at least in this industry sometimes.
Like I'm a funny fat guy.
I'm not going to be a funny skinny guy
when I, you know, Kevin and
I, when we were young, um,
when we first moved to
La in like the 1990s, um,
he had an agent at the time that I
talked to him in a firing. But, uh,
that's one of the things that his agent
said to him, when you're losing weight,
you're losing roles.
Oh,
he told them not to be healthy because
it's bad for your career. And He,
and I was saying, do you look around,
look at all these people on TV? Yeah.
Are they all fat? Is it the only way
to be on TV? Do you have to be fat?
W what are you telling me? You're not
going to be funny if you get skinny.
You're funny. You're funny.
Cause your brain dude,
your brain's going to work better
if your skin here. It's for him.
Kevin doesn't have any real vices. Like
he doesn't drink, he doesn't smoke weed.
He doesn't like to do drugs.
He's his thing. His food,
he fucking loves food.
The way he talks about food is like the
way a guy who is getting out of 20 years
in prison talks about the first
sex he's going to have. Right.
You know he talks about this fucking his
chicken parm sandwiches. They got this,
this crust they have on them.
It's fucking just golden brown
toes did not bar but just slightly,
slightly brown and the sauce,
the sauce and the melted
Mozzarella Cheese and oh,
he'll talk about it like he just,
he told me about the best cheeseburger
place in Encino and there's apparently
this doughnut place and Encino,
Lucky's or something like that.
And they also have cheeseburgers. I never
went there because you know the fuck,
it's just a cheeseburger. I'm not
traveling for a cheeseburger. I mean,
how good could it be?
Yeah.
But listening to him describe
it almost got me to drive there.
It was like it like porn to him.
It's like porn.
It's clearly a vice.
Well that was the problem.
John Candy had,
you know it's a common problem there was,
I was talking to,
there was that movie he did summer
rental and I'm like 1984 or something.
And he was literally at his skinniest.
He's like ever been in any of his
movies when he was doing that movie.
I was talking to the guy who wrote that
and it was like one of the producers and
he said every day they would go in,
you know,
break into his hotel room while he's on
set and steal all the like food that he
had taken from the settled.
Yeah.
And like he had like he showed up
with suitcases full of junk food,
like at several suitcases
and they're like,
they had to literally take that stuff
away from him so that he wouldn't need it
and like Yo yo is weight while they were
shooting out of sequence or whatever
like and he was at a skinniest anyway,
he was still a big guy,
but some people have a problem with,
I've got a problem with it man.
And he's still ate himself to death.
Yeah.
Well I mean John Candy died pretty young.
I mean I don't even think
he was 50 wasn't it?
He was like 44 or something like that.
All from fat and I'll just eating
himself to death. He was so funny though.
Goddamn. That was funny. Planes,
trains and automobiles like God,
he was hilarious.
My buddies and I will do a John Candy
movie night every once in a while.
Just watch the John Candy movie.
Great outdoors. Yeah. I mean everything
in home alone, the poker, the poker.
It's so good, man. Uncle Buck is great.
They're doing an uncle buck show now.
They did an uncle buck show way back
in the day. Yeah. With somebody else.
That's weird. Well, maybe they
feel like enough times pass now.
I think it was Jim Belushi or something
like that. Oh really? Yeah. Oh,
I don't know that. That would have
worked. Well, obviously it didn't know.
Hold on a second. Uncle Buck TV
show. Oh, it was Kevin Meeney.
Oh, poor Kevin Christ. Yeah,
that was 1989 I'll all African
American uncle buck show coming soon.
No, African American. They're doing
a I Annie. That's the new thing.
Christ. That's hilarious.
That's weird. That's hilarious.
How they do that. Not that,
I mean, not that it needs to be a
white show, but it's like it just,
it's so calculated. Just make
another show, make a show,
and if I hire the best actors,
meanwhile salon.com will
praise it for its diversity.
It's amazing what they've done better
than the original because everyone's in
minority. Yeah. That show blackish
is pretty funny. That's a funny show.
But that show would be funny. I mean,
it's original. It's a for, you know,
it's a first run. They've no one's
ever done it before their show.
They created all the characters. Ian
Edwards writes on it, you know? Yeah.
Lawrence Lawrence Fish Burns on
his films right next to my house.
They've good fucking show, but it's like
they've got good writers. It's well done.
I mean,
it would be well done if they were
Chinese people be well done if they were
Polish right.
It's just a good show.
I can't wait until racism stops and dies
down to the point where it's no longer
addressed because it's so fucking annoying
watching shows that are so clearly in
response to like the the Brownie
points you're going to get,
the Social Brownie points you're going
to get for showing diversity. It's not,
the diversity was like it was
important because it needs to be done.
It's almost like it's done just
to kind of like score, you know?
It's done to like, look
what he'd done. Look,
we've got to be a woman and she's
Asian and she runs the show. Well,
there's a black woman
president. Our show. Yeah,
the woman President United States is
black and it's a woman on our show.
It's like, I see what you're doing. Okay,
you're doing like card tricks. Okay,
let's stop calling attention to
it. Getting those good point. Yeah,
just make it good.
It's Duh Duh.
Like racism is bad. Duh. I can't wait
until it's done. You know, like, I mean,
who the fuck do you know that's
racist in this day and age?
If I was hanging out with some,
Anthony Kumi might be a little race,
a little bit,
but the old school comics he's experienced
that guys experienced a lot of shit.
Being a white guy living in New York
and looking like him, things get rough.
But I think that,
and hopefully in our lifetime it'll
get to a point where people will,
other reasons to separate,
you know, the, the,
the idea of like right now you've
got people that separate because of
conservative and liberal.
You've got people that separate
because of religious and atheist.
So you've got people that celebrate,
set up separate rather because
of a Vegan and meat eater.
You know,
you've got all these little factions and
groups that separate from each other.
You know, Seattle fans versus
patriots. I mean, this is essentially,
we like to be in these weird little groups
and the group of white people, just,
just white people that don't
like minorities. Like God damn,
that's a fucking stupid group.
Like in a group of black people
that don't like white people.
Like that's a fucking dumb
group too. Yeah. He's, this
groups are dumb. Like the,
the idea of you're just one aspect of
your appearance or one aspect of your,
uh,
your ethnic origin.
It's one of the dumbest fucking things
to like associate with and it's,
it's tiresome. And the
response to it, the, the,
the opposite response to it
is almost just as tiresome.
It's almost like just we need to get to
a point where it's not an issue anymore.
So that these, like the making a black
uncle buck is going to, you know,
people gotta go, why would you do that?
Why don't you just make uncle frank,
you know, make a new fucking show.
Right. You know, you'd have to,
it doesn't have to be uncle buck.
It's not John Candy.
It's not even Kevin Meeney stop stopped.
Kevin Meeney gets, gets inserted
into this argument against his will.
When only that laid me out of him.
Find me a black guy named buck. Right.
Are there black guys named buck? Okay,
let's, let's Google black guys named buck.
I'm never even met a white guy. I mean
all the bucks have been like buck Rogers,
uncle buck like from the fucking fifties.
I when I worked at the radio station in
Phoenix, uh, it was owned by Buck Owens,
the legendary country, sir.
Wow. Images for black guys
named buck. It's quite a few.
There's some fucking ridiculous
images of black gentleman named buck.
Now it's a lot of white people. The Jack
Johnsons in there. His name's not buck.
Fuck you. This is ridiculous.
Fits as a Google image search.
Black guys name Buck, and then pictures
of Christina Hendricks. Boobs come up.
And then buck angel. Do you know buck?
So Buck Angel Angel was on the podcast.
Used to be a woman is now man.
Oh Wow. Transgender porn star.
All yoked and shit. Pretty
rare. Really good guy too. Yeah.
Fun Guy to hang out with.
Talk to named buck black white as fuck.
But I Google black guys named buck.
Nope.
There's so few black guys named buck do.
You don't even get past the first page.
The first you get one row of black
people before you get white folks. Right.
And couple of them look at those photos.
Yeah.
They might not even be really named
buck. Just be black people. Yeah.
Those are just buckeyes.
Those Ohio state. It's true.
So Ohio state,
just two of them were Ohio state and
two of them are like pictures from back
when they, you know, one of
them said one of them is a,
is a whole website on blackface.
Yeah.
Well the history of blackface, that's
where the image comes from, which has got,
okay, so the, okay, so that
guy buck was not even, oh,
he was a black man.
All right.
Black is a weird thing.
Like you can't do black face today.
Like someone was playing
a character like a, at a,
a party, like a Halloween party
and they put blackface on and um,
they got fired from their job because you,
you can't pretend to be a black person.
Like you cannot have black person
makeup on if you are a white person.
I successfully did it cause
I was at black wizard though.
Now you didn't successfully do it dude.
Nobody knew about it.
Nobody knew about it. When you can't get
fired from your job, you work for me. No,
I mean I mean I went to
parties and never went.
No one ever said anything because I was
playing almost like a superhero kind of
character,
you know.
But it was a black face and heart is
did you go to though the southpark party
and then I went to a couple bars,
Gilmore more girls.
Let's see here what I'm saying,
like you're not working for a company.
What I'm saying is that
there was a company and they
had a party and they had a
Halloween party and this guy showed up
in blackface and they fired him and it
was this issue like like, come on man,
he's, he's playing like Mr t, you know,
we had like gold chains on and everything
and he put black skin colored makeup
on. You cannot, you literally cannot do
that. You can pretend to be from avatar.
You can pretend to be a lot of things,
which you can't pretend
to be as a black person.
You cannot darken your skin
color. Yeah, that's a weird,
that's a weird fucking rule. And Oh,
you and be your, when you say this,
and I've said this before on the podcast
and people will fucking freak out,
and the ultra sensitive search,
social justice warrior types,
we'll start tweeting. You do not
understand that. You sit ignorant.
You don't understand the context of
where black blackface gained from,
how offensive it is to people of color.
Fuck off.
Fuck off with your fake sensitivity.
I know what you're doing.
You brownie points search and
for assholes it's just skin.
It's just the color of skin.
It's preposterous.
The idea that you can't
play Denzel Washington, you
can't like, you can't do it.
You can't ever do it. You'd be, you have
to be the white Denzel Washington does.
Like what if I want to play Denzel
Washington for Halloween? I can't do it.
I'm a huge Denzel Washington Fan. I
loved all his motor girl could, no,
they can't get away with,
if they're doing black face with a,
as a guy as Denzel Washington, I
doubt it. There was no certainty.
Who's that actress that just got
in trouble this year for Halloween?
She did black face. Uh,
Julian is the new black.
Yeah. Oh yeah. She, she learns. So someone
from orange is the new black,
but she didn't,
did she get in trouble or was
that she was on TMZ about it.
It was all over the place about it.
Have you been following the
gender thing at all, Joe?
Of course. I have this, I'm white
teens in blackface. Yeah, there's a,
there's a bunch of these Missouri
high school girls wear blackface.
Outrage.
Outrage as a white high school seniors
in Missouri show up for girls powder puff
football game in blackface.
Look at this.
Don't Cook People in
Missouri that think they can.
They just think they can fucking
do anything like, well shit,
we're in Missouri.
We don't have to follow your liberal rule
anywhere near Ferguson. I mean they do.
They not watch the news too. They're not.
No.
They're not interested.
The racial tensions that are taking
place within their state. Yeah.
They're like, I'm staying in this
town. I ain't moving from this town.
This is where where I live.
They're all wearing blackface and they
have teachers around them that are all
smiling.
The images of white girls with their
faces painted black was posted on social
penia sparking outrage.
This is like some
serious blackface though.
They didn't even bother doing the
neck. No, they're just black face.
They're not pretending. It's not
called black men, not black wrist.
And that was a conversation they
had her arms. Everything is white.
Everything is white,
black or this.
Some of them have like a black
long sleeve shirt on. Yeah.
But they don't have gloves. That
chick planned ahead. Two of them did.
It's fucking, I dunno man. I mean,
look, racism is absolutely disgusting,
but you give a lot of people a
lot of power when you allow them.
You know, when you get so upset,
the principal said nothing racial.
This is hilarious. Oh my God.
From the fucking principle.
Nothing racial about the powder puff
team wearing blackface. Oh really?
I was nothing racial. They're pretending
to be a different race than they are.
That's very racial.
That's inherently racial.
There's no way getting around racial.
But here's the thing,
it's not bad to be black.
Okay,
so why would taking makeup and
turning your skin black be bad?
I could get, this is a racist context to
it, but it when, when is that dissolve?
I mean, at one point in time, do we
culturally just step back and say like,
this is ridiculous.
Somebody wants to be fucking Mr t.
If you're black and you're hanging around
with a bunch of white people in there
were legitimately your
friends and you love them,
and one of them decides to be mister t
for Halloween and shows up with a bunch
of gold chains. He's got a Mohawk on
and he's got black face on. Right?
Are you going to beat him up and get to
beat your friend out for being racially
insensitive? I mean, are we really
living in that fucking retarded?
A world where that's such a huge issue.
It just seems racism is disgusting.
Racism is evil,
but someone playing another race
by putting makeup on their skin.
The only way that would
be negative at all,
the only way is if there was
something wrong with being that race.
There's clearly nothing
with being a black person.
So someone who is white putting black
makeup on, it's not like they're,
it's not like they're doing al Jolson
and they're putting white around their
lips and black in there.
Man, they're there.
They're doing some sort of a fucking
horrible racial racist or mass.
Uh, yeah, exactly. Obviously you
exactly this, this person who got fired,
he was playing a famous black person,
but it's out of bounds. Like you
cannot do it. You can't do it.
There's a witch hunt going
on in this country. You know,
just like the moment someone mentions
any sort of race, you're racist.
It's such a great way to diffuse
someone and take all the onus off them,
take all of the possible scrutiny or
criticism that might come their way and
point it all at you. It's also a
great way to diffuse your argument.
Just call you a racist. You know, like if,
if you have a different opinion
about Ferguson or about, you know,
economics or Al Sharpton or any,
anything that involves a
black person instantaneously,
your arguments diffused. If they call
you racist. Yeah. Well, Josh Mcdermitt,
you're a racist. You're from Phoenix,
Arizona, one of the most racist states.
Come on, man, you're a racist, fake. Why
don't you just own up to your racism, man?
Yeah.
There's no way around that.
You can sit there and argue it and they
just keep throwing that back at you and
you get,
you could get hashtag black lives
matter tattooed on your forearm.
People sign till they
would still go after it.
There was still it's cause it's,
it's a way that people,
instead of it being a rational thing.
Who was that Ted Danson. Oh that's right.
Black face when he was dating
Whoopi Goldberg did it on TV. Yes.
Well he had a pass. He thought because he
was dating wipie he's like, look at her,
I'm fucking her. I should be able
to do something about this. Ah,
I forgot about that.
That kind of started it all.
I feel like that's starting to
dance. It's fault. Well the,
I mean it was offensive
at one point in time,
especially because at one point in time
that was the only way you saw black
people represented on TV.
It was a white person playing a
black person or in movies was,
or they were slaves, you know. I mean
you had like go back like other races,
like go back and watch John Wayne played
Gingiss con you told me that's not
fucking offensive.
He's playing a Mongol and he's clearly
this fucking corn fed white guy from
America and he's playing like one of
the most important historical conquerors
ever. Right. And he's playing them out of
the race. He doesn't even have makeup on.
I mean,
he's not even fucking pretending.
At least the guy who played
Jackie or um, uh, Charlie Chan,
like they did something to them to
make them look more Chinese, you know?
But John Wayne, they just said fuck it.
It's John Wayne was, he's gang guys.
Can that to a, yeah, I mean
if you ever watched it. No I haven't. Oh,
it's Gloria. I think I've seen pictures,
but yeah, I haven't seen it is
glorious and it's stupidity.
It's so fucking bad.
It's so bad.
And you realize like it was one of
those Elvis movies where they would just
fucking slapped together.
There was a point in time where
they would slap together a movie,
have Elvis in it and just,
you know,
Elvis is a football star and
we've got a wooden the scream,
we've got to look in this case.
And Elvis was started dancing.
They would do that with John Wayne.
I mean they would,
they would let John Wayne play Gingiss
Khan and one of the shittiest fucking
movies of all time. Or they just
didn't, they didn't do any makeup.
They didn't like darkness
scan once. Yeah, Jamie,
pull it up and put it on the screen. So
only we see it. So the, the folks in,
so we don't get pulled from youtube.
If you have a videos that people have
copyright on them and you play them and
then you upload it even from a
podcast where you're talking about it,
he played on Youtube, they
pull, it sucks. Yeah. But we'll,
we'll put it up on here.
Just, just for the, he,
he's in the hos because you got
to see how fucking bad it is.
LG USA low though. That's
crazy. It takes me back.
That's the USA logo.
And remember that same movie.
Oh Wow.
That's graphic.
Yeah. He just had the chew
man Fu Mustache. That's the
only Fu Manchu and Manchu.
Yeah.
Madison is a stupid
and he's banging white chicks.
Super White. Look how hot Cheetos,
God damn women that were hot back then
too. There were hot in a different way,
man. They were, they were hot
in this like supernatural.
Like when you say hourglass really was
like an hourglass cause they had about an
hour until they turn into old ladies.
They didn't last.
Like I was out of fucking of
restaurant the other day. Um, and uh,
I saw Cindy Crawford and I don't
know how old Cindy Crawford is. Well,
I want to Google right now. I'm going
to guess 50. Make us 40. No, she,
she's at least 50. Um, she is hot as fuck.
She's 48. Dude. She's hot as fuck. Yeah.
Like she's hot like 25 year old hot.
Right.
Because that bitch is probably
running stairs every day, doing yoga,
getting her face. Sandblasted getting
stem cells from aborted fetuses,
sprayed all over cheekbones. I
mean, I don't know what she's doing.
Whatever she's doing,
she needs to write a book because
at 48 she's fucking stunning.
She's stunning. She's a year older
than me and I look like, shit,
let's go. Come on. You look good. I mean,
I don't look totally Shitty,
but oh,
I just don't look as good as I looked
last year. That's all I'm saying.
That's fishing for compliments.
That was the whole point.
I'm going to make them a story about
seeing her at the restaurants and they're
telling me, I look at it by her
body's in check or faces in check,
like there's nothing sadder than you.
You run into, I won't say the name,
but I ran into this woman who was a
major movie star in the 90s now she is
enormous. I mean, she's probably 50
60 pounds overweight or face licked,
all fucked up. And she looked
like she smoked cigarettes
and just, and I was like,
no, that's not. No, because
before she was just dawning,
you would see here and just go,
good Lord. And now it's just, yeah,
same thing just happened to me with the
girlfriend, Wayne's world. Oh, really?
See them.
They're all white.
They want to know who it is that
you're talking about. Did big,
wide wasted lazy fucking,
who is it? Just say here,
this shitty food down or radio. It is. I
can't think she lives in my neighborhood.
You still talked to Betty White?
Betty White, you know Betty White?
He used to be on a show with her.
No, I wasn't. I was on a net.
I was on the same network,
but we would do parties.
What's the show that used to do
the retired at 35. It was, um,
I thought she was on that show. What does
retired at 35. It was a Sitcom I was on.
Um, we went two seasons with
George Segal who was on that show.
Just shoot me and then I can't
think of the woman's name.
Jessica Walter who was from Archer and uh,
uh,
arrested development. She plays a mom
and all that. She was red, but Betty,
I don't know Betty. Yeah, I
just saw the Betty White nudes.
Somebody sent me the other day and her
naked when she was younger. Beautiful.
She's beautiful by white. Had nudes.
She has a lot of them and there's like,
it's like really whoa, those are
real. Yeah. Yeah. She's really,
she's just a beautiful person. The
casting couch was a real thing back then.
It really was, but still real, right?
Yeah, it's still is. It must be.
I mean I'm probably not
for like big budget movies
probably so probably for like
everything man. Stuff like the conqueror.
It's kind of implied though, right?
Isn't that the thing about the casting
couch? Just not as simple as like,
hey look, get on that couch and
chuck, Mr [inaudible]. Right.
I think it's put you in x men
five. No it doesn't. You know,
is he gay? I don't know. I mean I think
he just likes parties with naked boys,
young boys in oak tub filled
with blood. Did you see the, the,
the pool is like red lights
in the pool and he's like,
I'm like running around banging
each other. I'm like, God,
I say why not? And we're still
asking if he's gay. Oh he's gay.
He's gay as fuck. He's gay as fuck. Cause
I taught there was, I dunno, there was,
I mean this is how stupid
and out of the loop I am.
But I thought there was
something that like,
I just assumed he was based on these
allegations and all of the things he went
through. And then there was something
where it's like, oh a god. Ah,
why not all blow up bud, but whole blood.
That's what I'm saying. It's crazy.
Red Lights, red lights. Well they
probably put fucking die in there too.
You know,
they'd probably
put dye in the pool. Let's look a fun
time guys having a good fucking time, man.
He's, I see a couple of gals
there too. A couple of not enough.
Wow.
A couple of gals who want to be able to
have fun and not have people try to put
this guy in the foreground with his
hair. Like what? That's a bad haircut.
Shave your head homie. Just let it
go. So over, trust me when it's over,
it's over. But you know, like
these guys that he, you know,
he banged that he, that he brought to
these parties, they would get upset.
But I think the thing was
that there were underage,
there were like younger than 18 that was
like the, the real issue. But you know,
that's one thing about underage sex.
People give zero fucks if
you're an under aged gay boy,
I feel like a 17 year old gay guy
likes to blow Hollywood dudes. Right?
But if you were like a girl
and some Mel Gibson type guy,
some big Hollywood celebrity guy had
parties and add a pool filled with 16 year
old girls and he was banging. I
mean that would be the end. Yeah,
that'd be the end. Absolutely.
But if it's boys, I'm like, Damn.
They wanted one of their owners.
They have boners at 17 they all gained,
they're all gay, right? There's no, no
one, no one got roofied. Okay. Yeah.
Were before we're done here, get out of
here. Get out of here. He had texted me,
I was 18 did you have sex with you when
you were 19 and then 20 and 21 yeah.
Okay. We're good. It's the same
thing. Same thing happened.
You didn't know what was going on. Was
it the first time you'd ever had sex? No.
Did He, did he give you some
drugs? Did He roofie you?
Did he do something to you that's just
so want to have sex with mister singer?
Obvious when someone's trying to get
a pay day, you know that, I mean,
I don't know the details of this case,
but it's like this guy like sat on this
for like 15 years or something like that,
didn't he? Yeah. It's just like, come
on. Well, yeah. Well they definitely,
I mean they feel like they're entitled,
you know, it's like they, they could sue,
they might be able to get money, so go
for it. I don't have any money. I'm broke.
Hey,
I fucked Bryan singer and all of his
friends in a pool six years ago when I was
only 17 and you go to
a lawyer and he's like,
do you have any photographs from Mr
Sanger and you in this pool and said pool
with no clothes on. As
a matter of fact, I do.
You pull those photos out and then
they say, listen, let's go to this guy.
And it's essentially,
it's a money grab.
You're trying to get money and
like you'd say, listen, Mr Sanger,
it's going to cost you about $5
million to fight off this lawsuit.
We are bringing in the big guns here at
Sherman and Lefkowitz and associates.
You know, we have a long history
of extorting money from large,
rich celebrities like yourself.
So let's just, uh, let's,
let's call it 3 million and let's
wrap this pitch up tight right now.
And they make these negotiations and they
fucking give him some money to fill it
out and there you go.
They signed some sort of a disclosure and
it encourages people to continue to do
that. Well, the UFC is in the
middle of thinks three or four,
um, class action lawsuits
now. So some of them,
which I just don't understand
what they're doing.
I like guys that had no chance of
ever winning a belt ever. They were,
they were not that good. They were,
you know, marginal fighters at best.
And I don't know what they're suing over.
I don't understand it.
They as soon over. I think the
idea is that somehow or another,
the UFC stifled competition,
but according to the people that I know,
obviously I'm only hearing one side of it,
but that it's going to cost
them $25 million to fight it.
And they get approached by these lawyers
and a while they're going through the,
you know, the whole legal
issue of what, you know,
what could be considered
a anti competition,
what couldn't be they,
they start accumulating legal bills and
then once the bills start getting high,
then they, they pulled them together,
they have a meeting and I say, look,
here's the deal. You know, we'll settle
for 10 million and we'll settle for,
you know, 9 million. What do you
want to know? What do you want to do?
And then they make a few million and
then they fucking high five each other.
They go get some hookers that
they drink some wine and they go,
we got another one. I mean, there's
some legit class action lawsuits. Most,
certainly when a products fail and
people die, um, like there's a,
there was one recently with Chevrolet
where it turned out that they hid the fact
that their ignition switches we're
fucking up and a bunch of people that died
because of this.
And so there's like some legit class
action lawsuits when it comes to certain
companies. But uh, when you see Bryan
singer type thing and like, okay,
wait a minute, you're gay, right?
You're good. He's gay. Okay.
You showed up at his house and there
was a bunch of gay dudes and you're all
doing gay stuff. Okay. And you want
some money? Like you look, you get dick,
that's what you get.
He went to the party.
You wanted to get some Dick got some Dick.
You probably got some ecstasy to bonus.
Okay. He probably gave you some food.
You probably had some snacks.
Like a sandwich is burger from
this donut shop and seeing
it's phenomenal mouth.
You got to party in the red pool.
Hopefully you didn't have to clean
up after. Everybody's fine, man.
You weren't the guy that has scrubbed
the fucking the red stain off the side of
the pool and I'm like, it
was probably that Easter egg
shit, you know, through the,
you know when you do with kids dunk eggs,
oh yesterday drop those
little pellets into the water.
It turns red food dye and they get out
of the pool and they're just all red.
He can't get away with that kind of
shit anymore. But back in the day,
like who could you imagine if you could
go back to like the 1950s in 19th like
the Humphrey Bogart days,
what kind of fucking chaos those
parties must have been like when no,
there was no accountability. The studios
totally protected people. I mean,
you'd have to have a dead body before
shit got weird and you would literally
have to have some, someone would
have to be dead. And even then,
and even then probably you
wouldn't know about it. Yeah,
I mean we first show or there must
have been some stars that had to call.
Like what does that show
that's on showtime that I'm
Ray Donovan, Ray Donovan.
We call the Ray Donovan Guy
and Ray Donovan comes over,
he fixing fucking wraps the kid up
in a of of of some sort of a carpet
cleaner. Yeah, they,
they take it downstairs and they fucking
throw it in the furnace and that's it.
That's such a good show. Is it
a good show? It's a great show.
I only watch a couple episodes. I see
what you saw. The first episode where he,
he goes to the girl's stocker and
he's sitting there, you want the bay,
what's in the bag or the bat? And
the guy goes, I'll take the bag.
And then he makes them get in
a bath full of like, you know,
green dye or whatever. And then the guys
just like, his skin is green, you know,
it's not going to wash out for a while.
He's just humiliated and everything.
That's probably what happened
with the Brian Secrets Party.
To be a girl celebrity I think would
be really scary because there are dudes
that fixate on female celebrities in a
really fucking creepy way and today they
can find where they live. Oh yeah. It was
very easy. I was drug the other day. Joe,
I told you about it and that scared the
fuck out of me cause that was the first
time where I actually felt like
something's not right with me.
I don't know what's going on. And then
I wake up an hour later and I'm like,
what the fuck happened? We'd like where
am I? And it was, it was so scary.
And I and I talked to girls
about it. We're like, yeah,
I've had that happen a couple times.
There was a party,
they have that happen all the time.
They have this nail Polish. No,
I'm restart wearing though. I could just
get my finger in and it changes color.
If there's any roofie in there though.
Well I think it only works for
some drugs or does it work for Ghb?
Like if you dip your finger in it and
it's roofing all, maybe it'll work.
We'll do it for everything.
I think maybe each nail has a different,
yeah, have a drink. Hold on. That
was just my roofie nail need.
Let me check my Ghb nail.
Alpha males.
Alpha males now have the roofie for
guys. They turn, they turn hearts.
Pink hearts shows up on your nail if it's,
if it's a negative, but it's weird is,
I told you this already,
but I got roofie at a bar and it was,
you know, everything just went spinny bar.
Were you at? I was at jumbos clown room.
Well that's a roofie hotspot.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean it's, it's,
it's a nice little feed
themselves at Jumbos. Yeah.
Just cause what am I doing with my life?
Most people end up there.
They've been roofie two shots
of Ruthie's. Yeah. Fuck it.
Let's go for something different.
When you wake up,
what do you got on the top shelf there?
Yeah.
They do actually take people,
Take Ruby's on purpose and,
but this was completely different than
who the fuck takes roof. He's on purpose.
It's, it's serious. Like kids or do
it as a drug. They take cap, you know,
there's little, a five hour energy
drinks, whatever they're called,
five hour energy drinks.
They fill that thing up with roofie shit.
And then they take,
they're called caps and they take a little
cap and they put it in and makes you
feel really like, uh, like, like body
buzzy. Oh you mean Ghb? GHB. Yeah.
Which is one of the, one of the
date rape drugs. There's non,
yeah, right. Not roofie
like roof and all that
bad one. Yeah. I don't know which one.
Mine was. Mine Cintas was, I was uh,
I was on my second or I just had my
second drink and I ordered a new drink,
took like one step of my third drink
and then everything started getting
spinning like, like by vision, almost
like trippy, like, like I couldn't, like,
I was like, why is it the room spoke
with your drink. What were you drinking?
Just a little Jack and cokes. Uh, and uh,
cause you were saying that so and take,
they take like advising bottles
and squirt it into people.
A bouncer told me what they do
is they take advising, bottle it,
fill it with whatever the crap they're
using and they'll just like literally
keep it in their hand,
walk through and just drop like
why they walk by somebody drink,
just drop it in there. And
uh, he said that roofing guys,
roofing guys is actually,
he's seen it before where like there's a
guy talking to a girl they want to talk
to so they'll re roughly the
guy to get him out of the way.
Like he'll start getting sick or whatever
and go to the bathroom and I passed
out.
Yeah.
I never take drinks from people.
I don't know unless I see it
come from the bar, you know,
into their hand into my hand is just
too many Weirdos if you don't know them.
Right. You know, you never know. Some
people are like aggressive, but hey man,
come on, do the shot. Yes, I know
where that shot come from. That's shot.
Could have come from Mars.
I see it in your hand.
I have no idea where it was
before it was in your hand.
It's, and it's not just
being roofie or you know,
like you could grab a guy's drinking.
Like maybe he was, you know,
the other night I did, I saw a guy and
he recognized me and I just, as a joke,
I grabbed his drink and started
drinking it and I got mad. I'm like, oh,
I could he be like having the flu right
now and he's still out. You know, it's,
it's good to just do your own drinks. It
was really weird though, because I pay,
luckily it got to my car and I passed
out and I, cause I couldn't see,
my vision was gone. I didn't feel drunk,
I didn't feel sick. I just couldn't,
my eyes weren't working so close my eyes.
And the next thing I know it woke up an
hour later in your car, in my car and,
and I felt, uh, muscle relaxer.
Well,
you gotta be really careful about that
because of a cop knock on your window.
You're going to just send
my backseat. Yeah, I know.
Even if you're in your back seat,
if you're in your car,
I think if you keep your keys and put it
on the roof, something like that. Yeah.
I mean something completely ridiculous.
But look,
it's essentially they have the
opportunity to arrest you for, right.
It's a technicality, you know, you
can tell them, look, I'm not driving.
I just sat here because I knew I can't
drive to like get out of the car.
They arresting you.
Yeah.
Which is fucking really gross
because you're doing the right thing.
You realize you can't drive.
You're just locking your door
and letting yourself sober up.
But there's certain Conti fuckhead cops
that will drag you into jail for that.
That's ridiculous. And
the next day, a whole day,
I just felt like I was like on
muscle relaxers. It was fucked up.
That's probably GHB. Yeah. Somebody
probably whacked you out because, uh,
I have friends who've done GHP before
and they've done too much and then they
just go limp. Like they'll be
at a bar and then like Eddie,
Eddie did it once and he did too
much. Wow. And, uh, he just like,
like couldn't walk or his
body just stopped working.
This, his body's went limp.
Yeah. Like my mind was normal but my
body was drunk and my eyes were drunk.
That's so weird, man. Do you have
any idea who might've done it? No.
I mean there was a lot of crazy,
I mean,
David Arquette was there
and so I said hi to David,
but there was also some people
that I knew there and uh,
I talked to them for a bit,
but then I,
I'm like been replaying it over my head
over and over again and I can't think of
it like, I could almost think that maybe
what if I just grabbed the wrong drink?
Like I grabbed a stripper's drink
by mistake or something or a wow.
I was trying to roofie them.
Yeah. Who knows? I mean, you
might have been annoying.
I was only there for an hour though.
I like,
I literally had a spot and I was driving
home and I was driving by and I'm like,
Oh, you know, I haven't been there
in a while. I'll just go in there,
have a drink or two and you stop eating
by yourself. Yeah, that's a real migraine.
So no, my friend, my friend,
my friend's a dancer there
and contortionists that's
a real alcoholic will pull
into jumbos or couple hours,
ride out the storm.
Three drinks in an hour. That
could be it too. No, no, no.
And these are like the small
little rock glass drinks, you know?
I mean I drink seven or
eight of those a day.
You don't know who you're dealing with
here, dude. I don't, I really don't.
You never drank with Brian? No.
Are you a big drinker? Yeah.
You want a little drunk right now?
No scared. Yeah. What's the matter?
I'm sitting next to Brian. You're
amongst friends. He didn't know
I saw what you had in there. I didn't.
It didn't entice me. Nothing. Makers.
We've got some, some. Oh, when we
put talked about on the podcast,
somebody contacted me about giving
us a wine cooler for, for wine.
Not like a wine cooler.
I wouldn't drink that cause I'm a man.
I don't drink wine coolers.
Now
are you talking about I drank Zima if
they don't even have [inaudible] anymore,
it's called something else, but it's
the exact same thing. It's flavor.
Hard time back in the day for drinking.
[inaudible] was great. Tastes good? Yeah.
Did you get drunk and it taste nice. Did
you remember to Kiza? Yes. What is that?
What was it?
It was like a Tequila beer or something.
Wasn't it like Bud light made it also?
It was like, yeah, it was just, it,
it was a beer, but it had like
lime flavoring in it and it had a,
but I don't know, it was Kinda
like a hint of it. Tequila,
I don't know if they were
actually mixing the two, but um,
like some of the worst hangovers I
ever had came off to keys, keys, keys.
It's so weird to keys up.
There it is.
What is this beer with a, a Gavi
nectar and a natural flavor of, uh,
imported Tequila.
So no actual Tequila,
but just flavors, right? Well, the
Gavi nectar is just sweet. You know,
a Gavi is,
it's actually not good for you.
You know when people like they don't
use honey. Like when I'm mock vegans,
one of the, that our mock, my,
my old special was about how they don't
eat like true vegans don't use honey
cause they don't think it's cool
to make this bs work for people.
But obviously not good for you. Nope.
It's sugar basically just sugar.
But it's better than like
Splenda or something. Would
you say? Nope. Nope. Nope.
And in fact it away.
SPLENDA,
it's probably better for
you cause splendid doesn't
give you the reaction that
you're going to get. Like the, the, the,
you know, the glucose reaction. Yeah.
Stevia is the best sweetener as
far as like health. It's like,
it's just a plant extract like Stevia.
It tastes sweet,
but it doesn't have any sugar in it
at all. It doesn't taste that sweet.
It'll look really doesn't taste as good.
You know,
the reality of Stevia is it's
like, it's like, like a bee sweet,
you know, it's not a sweet like, right.
I heard that there was even a new reports
that, that, that Stevia, there's good,
there's bad things about Stevia now.
Well that's as recent reports and
research was probably done by, you know,
the other companies that are getting their
asses kicked. Yeah. Come on man. I mean,
he has bad for you.
Hold on like every other week.
Something else that was good for
you is now bad for you. I mean,
it's a real problem with these fucking
people that create these tests.
Um,
hold on a second that we find out that
the results were skewed just because
someone funded them from some
company that has a vested interest.
Why I quit Stevia. Hmm. Okay. Let's see.
Is it like for rule of,
for a reasons and number
four will blow your mind.
Stevie attacks is the adrenals.
Our bodies are not designed or evolve
to handle calorie free sweeteners,
be it natural or other
official experiences,
sweet tastes from food that is not going
to provide glucose confounds our body
sugar handling process, I think. I think
it's like your brain pretty much goes,
hey, you know, this is sugar.
We need to work off the sugar.
But then when you go there, there's no,
it's not sugar. So fucks up the, yeah,
that's what they're saying. I
read it wrong. It's a sweet taste.
It comes from a food that's not going
to provide Glu Glucose confounds our
bodies sugar handling
process, whatever. Plus C,
I just switched back to normal
shit. Raw Sugar. Stevia,
all oh often contains other ingredients.
Oh,
there's an issue of purity. Hmm.
Hmm. We use processed Divia,
not pure stevia leaves.
Obviously you a pot of Stevia
leaves growing in your garden.
You can ignore this point, but there's
a bunch of other shit. Xylella tall.
That's another one, right? Yeah. Popular
sweetener made with Stevia and Xylitol,
although proponents bestow the title
natural to the sweetener. I've never,
I've never eaten trivia because I'm not
a fan of this Uber processed ingredient.
Oh, Trivia Trivia. Truvia
is Xylitol and Stevia.
Stevia has an aftertaste. Eh? Stevia,
diabetes. Yeah. I, aspartame is not
good for you too, but it's, you know,
when I think about all this stuff,
including diet coke, it's all
in moderation. Like, you know,
you can have a real coke if you want to
just don't drink them all day every day.
You know, I'm a, I'm a big
fan of cheat days, man.
I'm a big fan of just
eating really healthy.
And then one day going off the
mother fucking rails, you know,
and then bring it all back.
Just give yourself a little
day. We don't give a fuck.
It's hard for me to do that,
man. Only good for a week.
And then my cheat day turns into a cheat
month. Okay, let me ask you this spiral.
You say that, but you're
so happy right now, right?
You're so successful right now.
You've got so much cool shit going on.
Your on your favorite show mean like
life couldn't be better if you knew that
the only way to keep this running the
only way was if you ate healthy by some
strange metaphysical mirror,
Cole fucking magic thing.
Whereas like if you ate healthy food,
you're luck would continue to be
fucking amazing. But if you got lazy,
it has nothing to do with your
parents or your talent or your mind.
But if you've got lazy and deviated
from the path, your luck would change.
It would be eaten fucking lettuce,
lettuce wraps and bra fruit.
And you wouldn't fuck around at
all. Sure. But I love Mexican food,
man. I love salsa. You put down a
basket of chips. Now bring a second.
Like that's what I want. I'm,
I've never been one in a sweets.
It's always like the starchy carbohydrates
stuff. But do you ever have a case? Oh,
in Texas I've had it. I'm not
the biggest fan. Texas, I think.
I just haven't had great, yeah.
Ships in case. Oh, in Texas is a,
a totally different level. Before they've
Mexican food even comes, you're full,
you ordered chips in case
out, you know, they go, gee,
would you like some chips
and case out like yes ma'am.
They bring over some fucking case out
when you get to meet in some Jalapenos.
Oh yeah.
They were targeted case.
So that has like a cow in it
brightened up a cow. I got a,
I got a moose roast cooking at home
right now. Very excited. A press release.
Where are you getting the Mousse shot?
The shit out of that most. Oh really?
So this is him right here. No Shit.
Yeah, that's it. Yeah, that's it, man.
That's pretty Rad. It's delicious. But
I'm cooking it today. Uh, over 10 hours.
There's Moose roast in one
of those pressure cookers.
Oh, it's so delicious, man.
How many pounds of meat you get out
of that 400 shit. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Crazy. Did you have to buy a new
freezer or did you have it? Oh No,
I bought a separate fee. I
had one commercial freezer,
but after I shot the Moose,
I bought another one just to,
just to have the room for it.
You should experiment with
making jerky because dude,
I'm making all kinds of things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've been making,
I've been doing roasts.
Roasts are the new thing or do
it in the green mountain grill.
I see room on the
outside on a, um, like a,
of a cast iron frying pan. And then, uh,
I slowly cook it in the Green
Mountain girl for like 40, 45 minutes.
Cause you know, it's not, not that big.
A roast is only for like four people.
And then this one I'm doing
in a pressure cooker, but I'm,
I've got a bunch of recipes from
Steve Rinella sometime do meatloaf.
I'm going to make ground meatloaf with
spinach and cheese inside of it and
enjoying cooking.
Man,
cooking is fun and if you have the
time and you know you're so inclined.
It's a cool little art project.
Like I don't,
I don't never think of cooking is like
art but when it comes out it's good.
Like you get this little
kind of rd satisfies,
made something like I made this
and now we're going to eat it.
This is kind of cool.
There was this a video I recently saw
showing you how to cook the best steak and
you don't even need to use it grill.
What you do is you take
this big piece of meat,
you put it in the oven and you slow
cook it in the oven for like an hour or
something and then you just put it on a
really hot skillet for like two minutes
just as just a sear the outside and
it's like the perfect temperature.
It's like red throughout the whole
thing. Not like, you know, right.
Because when you cook it on a grill,
it's usually red in the middle
and then it slowly goes out.
You know where it's like less red,
you know the closer it is.
This is like right when he cut it in
all the exact color throughout the whole
thing. The way you do it
just got an hour. I get
that way.
I've seen that way too.
I've seen also there's a lot going
around with a boil it in water.
When those plastic bags,
they boil it at like not even boil it.
It's like hot water, like 125 degree
water, which is below boiling.
But it's like they keep it in there for
several hours and then you take it out,
sear it. And a lot of times people, they
cook the outside actually with a flame.
They take a like a propane torch
and they'll, they'll, you know,
they'll char the outside to get
like they're crispy outer edge.
I've tried every single method to
cook like a regular beef steak that my
favorite by far is lumped
charcoal on a regular grill.
You get that smoky real would taste to
the stake and you just gotta know how hot
it is. It's like a trial and error
thing. You got to know how for me, I,
I take like a two inch stake.
You need three minutes on each side and
then I put it on the upper level of the
grill. I close the lid and I cook it
for another five minutes. That's it.
And that kind of gets the inside. Bam.
I've been doing that for like, oh,
that sounds so, it feels so good. So bad
for people who don't eat meat. I know,
you know, I understand. I get it.
I get the morals and the ethics,
but those cows are going to dine them and
I want you to do, you're going to die.
My cousins have cows and they just, they
just, uh, send them out to get butchered.
Only got like 1700 pounds of meat.
Wow. My Buddy Doug, does it himself.
Sanity does he,
my friend Doug has a,
he has grass fed cows and his farm in
Wisconsin and fucking picks him out.
That's where I started getting bummed
out about grass fed cows cause everybody
has this idea, oh, CRAs had
cows. It's so ethical. You know,
my cows are only grass fed there.
You go near these fucking
cows and they panic and run.
They know exactly what you're there for.
Make no mistake about it.
This isn't like hunting. This isn't
like, you know, you see a deer.
The deer might not have ever even seen
a person before. Boom, the gun goes off,
the deer's down. That's
a, that's an ethical life.
These fucking cows to live in this,
it's
smell it, dude. They know. We went near
them and they fucking ran like we were.
Demons like were demons that
have corralled them up for
slaughter because that's
what we are to them.
You saw the cows being released from
the milk barn for the first time there
where they're all jumping around like
dogs and having a like there was so happy
that you just sat there and go,
wow,
they are so happy right now that there
you could tell that there's just like
crying with happiness. Yeah. Yeah.
They were trapped in those stalls for
their whole life and then they released
him out in this field and
it just dancing around. Wow.
Having a good old time with grief.
I think it's a fucking,
it's a real shame that somehow or
another factory farming has become a real
accepted part of the way we get
food in this country. But that said,
I like mate.
I mean it's so good.
I just tried goat for the first time.
I had to go before had goat
tacos and Houston. Yeah. Tacos
as well. We did. They do.
It was an Arizona.
Yeah,
but why are you saying Ooh
to that? Like, you know,
like 90% of the world eats goat. I don't
like go, go taste good. Have you had it?
No. I mean I just don't like goat's
so I don't think I want to eat.
It's all in your head, dude. I'm telling
you, you wouldn't like a lot of things.
You, you know, if you hang out with
chickens, you realize they're assholes.
You know, I told Ya chickens
bite my daughter's face.
I'm like, you fucking cunt.
I'll kill you. Chicken dinosaurs. Man,
they're dinosaurs. I mean it costs $3
in my chickens are sweet, you know,
cause they get pet and they get picked
up and they'll still bite your fucking
face. They're stupid as shit. Their
brains, your thumbnail. I mean,
literally society,
they don't know what's going on.
They're not doing it on purpose.
They're just trying to survive.
Do you have a problem with
coyotes getting your chickens?
I saw coyote get my chicken. Oh
really? Yeah. Oh my God. I have to get,
I've been slacking on this, but I have
to get a, I have to hire someone who,
they have this urban coyote capture
thing because the thing about we have 20,
well we used to have 24 chickens.
My dog killed one and the
coyote killed another one. Um,
but I saw the coyote jump my fence
with the fucking chicken in his mouth.
So I realized, okay, now
I see how the coyotes,
I had a fountain that was near the fence
and the coyote would jump to the top of
the fountain and jump over the fence.
I was like, Oh, you son of a bitch.
So I took the fountain down and a
reinforced the areas where the coyote was
getting in,
but they know there's food there and
they know there's a lot of food there.
There's 24 or 22 now,
22 chickens,
so I have to hire somebody.
They do.
These are urban traps and they
set them up all over at my,
I don't even live in or
I'm not an urban area,
but they set them up around your house
and they capture these coyotes and they
fucking Bang, Bang, I'm
going to kill him. Wow.
My cousins live urban traps like
a swap meet or something. Yeah,
urban traps.
It's a gold chain next to foot locker.
It's a pair of Jordan is next to then
one of those little lasso
hose or a noose ankle news.
Kanye is an issue is announcing is no one,
and I want to talk about it.
You don't like, no, I'm a fucking grown
man. I'm not. I'm not. You and Jamie
call each other on the phone and talk
about shit that nobody else gives you the
fucking phone mail
stop.
Just don't just don't Brown.
We have fucking Joshua
McDonald from the walking dead.
You want to talk about Kanye West and
you're 40 years old and want to talk about
Kanye and I've been telling him that
for years. He's a fucking grown man.
He's a grown man but he's not like somehow
or another when we stuck them out of
Columbus and brought him to Los Angeles,
we've stifled is growth.
It actually went back. He went
back, he was 30 then and he's 12
that's completely opposite of what
I've been figuring out lately.
Going through your own video out Joe,
do you remember when, when, when,
when I first moved here like,
like I didn't really have any friends so
like we would just like once in a while
like hang out and stuff.
There was like videos of me just sitting
in my computer and like my first week
here and I was like mentally challenged.
Retard.
I don't even know why you would
talk to me back then. I mean
that you do really well.
You don't even do I, I,
I've gotten back into it. Please go back
and I need to go on the road with you.
Sometimes they do some,
he's very talented.
Like his video editing skills are amazing.
That's what I initially hired
him for cause he's really good.
And then he became a podcast
in which he's challenged at.
He's challenged at communicating.
He's challenged to thinking about things
that challenge is often his strength
but his video skills I
think, no bullshit. No,
and I'm not saying this
just because you're here,
you're one of the best video editors
I've ever seen. Like your, your,
your like your sense of like timing
and like you're editing and the way you
splice things together, you create
something that doesn't exist like you,
you're capable of like you put these
weird touches on things and the weird
sounds and music and Ed,
you have a real feel for it man.
Like you have a real town.
Like if you really pursued
that you, you could be rich.
I mean you really could be. I
mean you should. You should.
You should be like a guy that people
seek out to make their music videos and
shit like yeah. Weird sense of how to
put things together. So real talent man.
Who edited your last special? I
did. Could have been common sense.
Brian. I don't see us having to
do with himself. How much editing.
It's just like that's a camera
cuts. That's what I'm talking about.
Like he did some stuff like look at
the Austin via is my favorite one.
Great one little Austin.
Yeah, with the dude that had
the there was born with, no,
no, no, no. I'm talking about the
Joey Diaz. It was me little Esther.
You share ideas and just
because the editing,
the audio editing because I remixed
music to go with everything and yeah,
it was funny that you're
really fucking talented with that.
I really think it's your calling in life.
You know? It's like as Joey Diaz
is meant to be a standup comic,
you're meant to be a video.
Have more fun doing standup comedy
to know because it's immediate.
It's immediate gratification.
But the you do shit that I can't do.
I don't have that mind.
My mind does not work that way.
I'm trying to get back into it.
And then this new computer,
it's finally getting to the
point where it's so much.
The rendering thing was the thing that I
hate it and I'm the reason that made me
stop. And we're just sitting
there waiting for hours. Hours.
What about those new Max, those
tubes, those super masc the tower.
Well,
it's funny because you'd think that would
be the best computer cause I almost,
cause I mean I just bought a new computer
and researching those, uh, you've,
you realize that they're using a different
processor that isn't really that good
for video editing as compared to the
I seven processor that the imax use.
So if you look at rendering times on one
of those machines versus a Imac and the
imac even comes across being
faster and a lot of the tests,
because those are used Xeon processors,
which aren't really,
I don't know why they use the,
so is it because the software
is optimized for that
processor? I think so. Yeah.
This is really boring. No one
[inaudible]
well, he would call me like, you know,
after he'd edited for like 12 hours ago,
I'm calling fucking crazy. Like I don't
think I could do the same. We're all,
I'm almost done, but I'm going
fucking crazy. Like, but the process,
the result was amazing. I just think
you've got a very unique talents.
That was awesome. Back in the days when,
when we are using mini DV tapes. Oh yeah.
So in order to edit I had to transfer
every single tape onto my computer,
then look at it and then go
through the 50 hours now.
I mean you just pull a card out.
Yes.
Slipped it in. What you should do
while you're single, you should,
you should do some sort of
a, a Brian reviews, massage
powers. I'm scared of that place.
Let's place this now. Yeah.
Cause my favorite place got busted and
now that they're off fake cops that work
there and yeah.
Do you go to jail? Do you go to jail for
going? You just got to play dumb. Oh yeah.
You go to jail. No, you just got
to play dumb. He's going to go,
how many here to get my feet rubbed
and rubbed my feet? Yeah. You know,
I'm going to get a foot massage. True.
You know? Do you want anything else? Hey,
whatever you want to do. I'm just
here. I'm just going to close my eyes.
You do what you want to do and if
you want a hundred bucks, you know,
you just do what you want to do. And I
just laid back. Good. I tip good. Yeah,
I mean, I'm a good tip.
I just liked massages.
I'm just going to sit here
and you know what I mean?
Going there because you got a little
something extra or was it they got busted
after the fact and you're like, wait,
I didn't even know. He doesn't know.
I don't know about rub maps and there,
this is my favorite website that I read
every single day. Oh, you do know it?
He's been all Hollywood on us.
Josh,
Darren,
you've come a long way since Phoenix.
No, I mean it's, it's,
it's, it's, but it's, it's,
it is something that also you
have to think about, like the sex,
the sex slave industry. Dang. You will
run into places where you're just like,
this person does not want to be here.
Like right now where I live,
this is one of the
craziest things I found.
There's this apartment or this bold house
next to me and they have like a garage,
a separate garage out back and
just this little small garage.
And I saw somebody come out of it the
other day and I'm like, what the fuck?
Why is there some Asian girl in there?
And then like a couple of days later
somebody opened up the door and there's
like four people living in this little
garage about the size of my car.
Like,
I mean it's just,
it's ridiculous and they're just living
there and that's the kind of shit that
freaks me out.
Yeah.
Okay. But is that just
people that like, you know,
some people come here from another
country and they're poor and they have a
relative, here are the
relative says, look,
you could sleep in my garage until you
get on your feet. We'll set up some beds.
It's warm.
We're in Burbank.
You don't have to worry about
it doesn't get cold at night.
Or are they sex slaves? I don't
know. Cause they, they looked,
they looked like they were
miserable. That's the reality of
prostitution being illegal. Yeah.
That's a big part of the problem.
If,
if prostitution was completely
legal and like a massage, I mean,
which it should be. I mean, I don't
want to give people massages. Okay.
I also don't want to give
him anybody any blow jobs.
But there's some people that don't care.
They don't, they like giving massages.
They don't mind giving blow jobs for 300
bucks instead of working at Denny's for
three days for 300 bucks,
you know,
and they wouldn't even get 300
bucks to work there for three days.
They could blow you for five
minutes and make 300 bucks.
Some people would do that and that's their
prerogative as adult human beings are
issue is legality and these weird
ethics that we attach to sexuality over
everything else we do. Like everything
else you do, where people serve you well,
people will serve you, drinks there, serve
you food. They don't fucking want to.
Nobody wants to bring you your
meat. Nobody wants us. Mr Mcdermott,
would you like some cracked
pepper on that salad?
He doesn't want to put fucking
pepper on your salad, right?
That guys only doing it because
he wants your money. I mean,
he's whoring himself out and I mean
this in the nicest way possible.
He's not really, but I mean, he's doing
it for money. You know, it's a job.
It's a great job. It's nothing
wrong with being a waiter. Don't,
don't get me wrong, but it's also
nothing wrong with having sex. I mean,
we have this crazy idea in our head
that sex is evil and nasty and Ooh,
you're paying for sex.
You get money for sex,
you fucking whore.
Somebody pays you and then they touch you.
You fucking bitch. You
know, like it's craziness.
Where we have these weird attachments
that are completely socially constructed.
We've decided that these things are pad.
The real issue is that stuff,
sex,
slavery,
that you're not talking about a
woman who's like just a grown woman,
a mature woman who decides on her own,
you know, it's just sex. Who gives a shit.
It's a,
it's a fine way to pay my bills.
I can go travel and I'll do whatever
the fuck I want with my life and I'll be
independent. It's not that
those are the, the victims.
The real issue is that when
you have things illegal,
then everything has to be CD
and hidden and uh, you know, in,
in the darkness and underground and
then you get things like sex slavery and
it's very analogous to the drug war.
One of the real reasons why the drug
war exists is because drugs are illegal.
The re one of the real reasons why
there's so much crime and Mexico that's
related to the drug trade is
directly because drugs aren't legal.
If drugs were legal,
you wouldn't have criminals that are
selling drugs and have criminals weren't
selling drugs.
You'd be able to buy drugs the same way
you go to fucking cvs and buy liquor.
There's no fucking gang wars over
whiskey. It's not happening, right?
Whiskeys sold and it's taxed and
everybody's hands, you'll be fine.
Other than the fact that people drink
it and do stupid shit weather on it,
there's no violence and no murder and
no crime attached to the production of
fine whiskey.
It's just,
and that's how it should be with sex and
that's how it should be with everything.
We are adult human beings. If you
want to pay someone to rub your feet,
you should be able to do it.
Could you imagine if like back massages
were somehow or another deemed morally
outrageous and you couldn't
go and get a massage?
Like you know those places at
the airport where you sit down,
you put your face in that chair and
they come over and rub your back.
What did they suck your Dick?
I've tried.
Okay,
I'll put a blanket over us.
I mean if you went to a place like
that and they gave you a hand jobs,
he'll be the most glorious thing ever.
If you went to that place and there was
a beautiful Russian lady and she took
you into this quiet room and she just
copped your balls with one hand and jerked
you off with the other. Oh well you
had an IPAD, you're watching porn.
Oh be greatest thing ever.
I want to know what consent,
like what's the difference between like
if you go on back page and you see they
have escorts than they have legit massages
where they bring a table over to your
house and they massage you. Then
they have the same category. Yeah.
Then they have body sliders where it's
like they bring like a big inflatable
raft that you have like in a swimming
pool and then you get naked and then they
put oil over unit and they just slide
their naked body on you and that you're
not fucking, but he's like, it's
that illegal or like what makes it,
you have to have insertion.
I mean,
it just doesn't seem
like escorting can be,
you can be caught for cause like
if you really, I don't know,
it just seems like, what's the law
without much first the slider though,
150 bucks usually for half hour.
Did,
did they define what a body slide or is?
Uh, there's videos of it. You can, there's
actually videos on youtube. Uh, it's a,
it's, it's, I mean it sounds
great, but you sound like that.
That's one of those things
where it's like, it's again,
it's like a cultural thing. Like what,
what does a body slider, you know,
like you have to define it because
like, you know, what's the sandwich?
Everybody knows the sandwiches,
some shit in between two slices
of bread. If you order a
sandwich somewhere, brings
you a pizza, you're like,
what the fuck is, this is what we
call a sandwich. You know what,
what do you call body slider in,
in northern California is the same as a
body slider in Chicago with the fucking
body slider man and sort of
a body sound sneaky shit.
Yeah. Body sites. Uh, and, and,
and you just sit there with like a boner
out and they just pretty much rubbed
their whole body on your, your boner
body boobs. Like it's just no insertion,
but pretty much everything else.
Is that illegal?
Um, I say no if no insertion.
I don't think it's illegal.
So it's just an assertion. But I think if
you come, it's probably illegal. Right?
That's where all the fucking,
that's where the Hullabaloo is about.
Orgasming nobody,
it's a bunch of haters.
They don't want you to come.
Is there like a five second rule?
Like if you company put it in your mouth
real quick and it doesn't count because
it's going back into your body,
that's disgusting.
Why is it disgusting? It came out
of your body two seconds, you know,
shut the fuck up. Seriously. Just think
before you say something like that.
Imagine that undercover cop who
got assigned a body slamming.
How about the undercover cop?
The watches him eat his own company.
Second rule.
I mean,
I always find it weird though.
Like if you have it
goober and your mouth and you could feel
it's one of those thick ones and then
you spit it on a piece of paper.
The idea of you'd now linking that back
up is the most grossest thing in the
rural,
but just a second ago you were in your
mouth just tasting it and true swishing
it around because
you don't think about it. It's
out of sight, out of mind.
You don't have to look at it. It's when
you look at it, you know, kind of gross.
It's like if you had to take a shit,
you know that's one thing you're like,
oh I can't wait to take a shit. And he'd
get on that toilet. Ah, it comes up.
But if you had a stuffed that
shit back in your asshole,
just if he had to reach in there with
rubber gloves on and just pack your own
ass, repack it. That might be one of
the worst things you could ever do.
Like taking a shit.
It's amazing
when you hold it in for just a little bit,
not a long time.
He'll look shit extra 20 minutes and
then you get on that toilet just ah,
you feel those logs just
fucking barrel and down the
river. Boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom. I went to, I took a dump
at the mall the other day.
I've been trying to eat healthier,
eating more Greens and stuff.
So it came out like very earthy.
Right. It wasn't anything horrible.
It just smelled and I flushed and then
the guy came in to clean the restroom and
started choking and I felt so
good and he just kind of get,
hear him like trying to clean up and
then he just go at the end, he just goes,
he was in there about two minutes.
He goes, it smells like fucking shit.
Like ah yeah. That was like a highlight
of my life. Like you scored on him.
He scored on him.
He fucking shit in a bathroom.
That guy's got to go in
there right after you
and I had flood. So it wasn't like
it was still sitting there stewing I,
it was post flush.
What?
There's nothing worse than when
you have to shit really bad.
And the only option is a Porta potty
and you're at a concert and there's 20
people behind you and there's a long ass
line and you go in there and you plop
down and you're shitting on other people's
shit that is on top of other people's
Shit,
which is on other people's Shit,
which is all in smurf juice and you just
drop in logs on top of preexisting logs
and just gagging.
Meanwhile,
the band's playing your favorite
song. Freebird no, fuck.
I was here. Did you? I saw this online.
They had a thing about the Porta potties,
like the whole point of him is you're
supposed to close the lid and then that
will take the scent out
up through this funnel,
like this tube and
release the sent up there,
but the reason port-a-potties smells so
bad it's because everyone just leaves
the lit up. No one wants
to touch it. Oh God. Yeah.
The deal is this is all bullshit. It's
stinks. It's a fucking confined space.
You're shitting in a phone booth.
It's not going anywhere.
That's smells everywhere.
As a society we could try it.
If it's still going to snake, we can at
least give it a shot on the walking dead.
Do you guys shit out in the woods?
Diedrich dropped blogs.
We've got trailers out there that
have like their air condition.
They're down to like 50 degrees so
it's like 90 degrees outside and then,
I mean I'm finding
excuses to take it dump.
Do you sometimes have like long
downtime in between scenes?
You could take a nice fat nap.
Yeah,
I still love those if you can.
I mean,
well because a lot of times because
we shoot on location, so everything,
it takes a while to get back to your
trailer where like I have a couch or
something I could sleep on
and so it's rare that a,
they would make you sit for that long.
How far away are you from like the set?
Like if your trailer is one place, how
far away is the set where you're feeling?
It's usually always less than 10 minutes.
You were telling us before that you get
there at five o'clock in the morning,
but when are you done? You didn't
just say when you were, um,
well we'll use up all the sunshine.
So like the sunsets about 9:00 PM and
Georgia 9:00 PM in the summer. Wow.
So you're working alone?
Yeah, the fucking date.
So they try and schedule it
because I think there's like a,
with the actors union, you have like a
turnaround, like you 12 hours, 12 hours,
and if they make you come back, you know,
shorter than the 12 hour turnaround,
they have to pay you. And
um, so I, I dunno. Yeah,
I'd actually, it's because I'm
a, I'm considered a local actor,
be a local hire because I live in Atlanta.
Then they,
there's like some rules around that where
they don't have to pay me all the time.
Did you get apartment in Atlanta or did
you rent a house or apartment and um,
when you,
when you come back to La,
did you keep an apartment in la or do
you just stay here for a little bit?
I kept one here and then I,
and I,
I'm going to have that as long as the
on the show cause I don't know when I'll
get killed off and I'm
not going to want to go find a new place.
I like where I live now.
Do you ever go to the producer and go,
listen, I'm about to resign my lease.
Is there anything I shouldn't
question?
Currently that happened with one of the
actors who are like at the start of the
season, cause they're secretive to us of
course, you know, but they were like, hey,
so I have a feeling I'm being set
up to be killed. Should I, you know,
I don't want to sign the lease. And
I'm like, no, no, no, no, you're fine.
And they went and signed the lease
and then they get killed. Wow. Dick,
did they go to them and to go, Hey, what
the fuck? Yeah, they were pretty upset.
But then there was another guy who,
who literally got it out of
Lawrence Gilliard who plays Bob.
The guy got his leg chopped off
and eaten by the cannibals. Um,
he didn't want to sign a lease because
he had a feeling he was about to go.
And so he actually got
the producers a talent,
like he like sat in the meeting with
them until he wouldn't leave until they
told him like,
yeah,
you're going to die in episode three or
whatever it was because he was about to
sign a lease. That's it.
Yeah. He's just like, look,
this is going to cost me 10,000 bucks
or 12 bucks. So he just didn't want it,
you know. I mean obviously you
can break a lease and you know,
but you're still paying for that.
But um,
he got it out of them and then
of course, like, you know,
they didn't tell us that he was dying
and I'm sitting there like texting.
I'm like, hey man, where
are you live in this season?
This and he's like radio silent.
And then I figured out that they were
going to kill him cause I'm like,
why would he be avoiding me right now?
Uh, it's not telling me where he's living.
It was just weird. You know, whatever,
when you shot, when you had that scene,
we shut that one scene.
We shot up the truck and like shut
the gas tank and all that stuff.
Like w w w how much of that was real?
Like did you, you were shooting a gun,
was it blanks where you
actually shooting at that car?
Cause it seemed like you were
actually hitting that car? Yeah,
it was half and half. So they
did. Um, so they give you blanks,
but then they tell you once you're out,
you know, just keep firing or mimicking,
like you're, you're firing the weapon
and then, um, you know, cause they'll,
they'll cut it around and everything.
I think there's only like 20
rounds in that clip, you know?
And I think if you really look at it,
I was probably fired like
over a hundred shots.
I'm fucking problem with revolvers,
but it's easy if fees,
it costs like five bucks to put
in a muzzle flash and like post,
you know, so they're like, you
know, so just keep jerking the gun,
like you're firing away.
And so I did that. And, um,
but then what they do
is they had these guys,
because we were right next to a corn field
and they had our special effects guys
like perched on some,
uh,
ladders with these like a paintball
guns with these exploding,
um, I don't know the
pellets that of spark off.
So like when I go and I shoot
up the truck, they're fine.
Actually the ones firing the truck and
BBB, BBB and it just hits on the truck.
So that was really cool cause they used
to have to like run this line of, um,
of charges or whatever and have those
explode at one time. Well when you,
when you kill a Zombie, like
what is actually happening? Like,
cause some of it is obviously
so CGI, right? Like the
blood looks fake. It looks,
you know,
some of it's not too realistic.
So they could show it almost like the
craziness of the blood is almost like,
you know,
varies because the one scene in terminus
when they beat the people over the head
and then cut their throat,
that looked real as fuck.
Well, it's super disturbing
with that. They had, um,
like these tubes that were just tied
around their neck and even everyone on set
was going like, oh, this looks totally
fake. And they're like, no, no, no,
we'll color that out later.
And the tubes were actually like gushing
out the blood and so when they cut,
you know,
so they,
they do the motion to cut and I think
they either had like a rubber knife or a
lot of times they have a knife that's
just the handle with something like green
tape on the end and it's so it's not
a full NY for machete sort of thing.
And then they paint that in
later. The knife is CGI. Yeah.
So that like if I got this water bottle
and there's no blade on the end of it
and I just use that and then they can
just paint that in and make it look like a
knife as a cut my throat. So cool. And
then they just painted out the, uh,
the tube so that all that was left was
just blood gushing out into the trough.
A pretty fucking awesome. It looks so
real. It was awful. That was brutal, man.
Well, that whole scene
was like, it was so,
it was hard to see how these
people could become those people.
It was so hard, especially when they
would show the background on them,
like how they, where they were when the,
the, the whole outbreak first happened.
Like they were normal and
then they became cannibals.
Then they're just treating their
marking down on clipboards where they're
beating people over the head with all
that conical. Yeah. It was really weird.
It was almost too over the
top because it was like, God,
I can't see anybody that I know.
Getting to that point where they
clubbed someone and turn them into us.
DESC yeah. You know, but, but at
this point you've got to survive.
You've got to eat terrifying. No, but
all that CGI stuff, Michelle and the,
the girl with the sword,
like her sword is fake usually.
And that's all painted in after the fact.
What is her sword look like when she
swinging it around? It's just the handle.
That's it. Just the handle.
Yeah. Just to handle.
They have no sorts so they have a real
sword but they rarely ever had it out and
use it.
You know like they might use it if she's
just like presenting it to someone or
whatever,
but then they have like a rubber sword
that looks exactly like it or plastic so
that you know for safety reasons,
but then they just have a lot of them
that are either like a half nub or just
know sort at all. Just the handle.
She has the best weapon. Sure.
That was one thing that I learned.
If the zombies are coming and then
not those 28 days later zombies,
they're fucking sprint at you.
If those slow as his armies,
you want to have a Samurai sword. Yeah.
I would have a great old fucking time.
That's one of the things that I didn't
understand about the prison when
everybody was like,
you know the,
all these zombies are pushing
up against that wall. I'm like,
there's not that many gimme a sword.
Let me, let me go out there and
fuck them are popping them. Yeah.
She just start fucking hacking heads.
Kind of the sad thing is that we'll
never really get to experience that. Oh,
you say that there were no, with all
these liberals and they're denying
of the Lord the Demon,
this may rise all this gay marriage.
It's transgender mayors and all kinds
of shit going on the world. I would, uh,
take that Samurai sword over basically
any weapon because it's not too heavy.
Like if you had like Conan sword, like
a big broad sword, that'd be tough.
That's heavy. You'd have to be real tough.
Some, you know, built like the Rock,
like an aluminum bat. Yeah. But
they don't always die. You know,
I, that's another confusing
thing about the zombies.
You just got to poke him in
the eye and they're dead.
Like it seems like you just get
into their head, their brain,
and it's super easy to stab
someone in the temple apparently.
And the knife just goes right in there.
Like,
get butter is that Zombie blood that
makes you a Zombie or any secretions
fucking like and be in the butt.
And when would you get become a
Zombie if you fucked us on me in the,
but I don't think so, but you're
already infected. So who cares. Yeah.
You already infected.
Which is weird because like when the guy
got bit last night and that episode he
got bit, but if he just caught arises
that wound, does he become a Zombie?
Um, ah. If I put them up,
think, well fuck them.
I'm not the expert on this thing through.
I don't think they thought they should
do. Yeah. Actually the whole show sucks.
I think if the, if the effect, you know,
cause you're already infected or you're
already, you already have what's in,
you know, that's inside of you.
If you die, you're going to turn.
But if you get bit and that infection is
going to come in and trigger whatever's
inside of you. So if you cut off your
arm like they did and cauterize it,
then you're probably okay. Because they
did that with Hershel and his leg. Yeah.
You know? Yeah. That was
weird. You know, that was like,
okay you just guys just fuck with the
rules because it used to be something
bites you and then it gets into
your bloodstream and like, you know,
well they've been fucking with the rule
since the beginning even in the pilot.
Um, cause zombies aren't supposed to have
any sort of like recollection of them
being normal humans.
And the,
there was like a little girl at that
gas station who walks by and just bends
down and picks up her little teddy bear
that was hers and Tucks it up and walks
away.
But her face is all mangled.
She sewed Zombie at that point cause
Frank Darabont was like, fuck the rules.
I'm going to do my own thing. I like that,
you know, he's going to medieval times.
It gets some chain mail. Right. When
didn't you just wear like a night? Yeah,
you would just dress
up, but yeah man. Yeah.
Do that riot police
like they have that uh,
the Kevlar you can't bite to
that shit would break. Yeah.
You can't even fucking stab some.
There's a guy who made the a,
the a shark bite suit. Did you
see this? Yeah. Yeah. And I,
so I did some a shark after dark
during shark week. Shark after dark.
Yeah. Have you heard of this
show? It's what, you know
Josh Wolfe, right? The comic?
Yeah. Yeah. So he hosts it and they just
talk all about sharks and all this stuff.
And um,
this guy comes on,
he had this like chain mail suit that is
supposedly supposedly a bite proof and
um,
they were stabbing.
Josh was wearing it,
they were stabbing him with the knife
and the knife was bending and they were
trying to stab him in the chest. But
the guy was showing us how, you know,
you can just take a knife and he had
the glove on and he was slicing like the
webbing in between his fingers and
everyone's like, oh my God, or whatever.
And then they gave me an ice pick and he
put his hand out and kind of like that
movie alien, I had to go in
between his fingers and do that.
And they told me beforehand, they
go, go ahead and like, you know,
pop them in the hand a few
times because he's not going to,
it's not going to hurt him or anything.
And so I did that and then I just
started just jamming the ice,
pick into his hand and apparently
I broke his hand. Oh my God. Yeah,
broke his hip, broke his hand. Josh
told me that Jammin it. Oh Dude, it was,
I was pounding, but I'm like, the
producers told me that it was okay,
but he's like, no. He was
like, oh, okay. And uh,
some people that were with me were like,
oh dude, I think you heard him. I'm like,
no, he's playing it up. They
said he couldn't get hurt.
Then Josh tells me like a
month later, it's like, yeah,
you broke that dude's hand.
Wow.
I felt good.
I am stronger than a shark.
That's the one thing
that would freak you out.
Like a shark got a hold of your arm.
It's a snap your fucking arm.
Like a twig swimming muscle.
Like I've seen a lot of guys get their
arms broken in fights where they get
kicked and they're blocking the kick in.
The Shin hits there.
I saw one just last night,
I was watching access TV legacy
kickbox and this guy got kicked,
blocked it and his arm just went limp in
the middle. Just start dangling luck. Oh,
it was crazy.
He and he's still fighting.
He's trying to throw a knee and he sees
his arm like flopping around to hear
about Hector Lombard. Yes.
Another one. Tests positives.
UFC and MMA in general
is a steroid epidemic.
Started this like really stringent
testing and everybody's getting popped and
just getting popped left and right.
It's one of the things that fighters
had been saying for a long time that
everyone's on steroids, you
know, a huge percentage.
Give him number 50 60 whatever the
fuck it is that are on steroids. Look,
apparently your,
your body just can't.
The idea of a normal training,
normal training camp,
which is fighters will work out
sometimes three times a day. They'll do,
maybe they'll run and do
like sprints in the morning.
Then they'll do some kind of strength and
conditioning in the afternoon and then
they'll do wrestling or Jujitsu
at night and they'll vary.
They'll the next day they'll do kickboxing
in the morning and running in the
afternoon and weightlifting
at night and they mix it up.
But you're talking about working out
three times in a day because you have all
these different skills
that you have to work on.
You have to work on your wrestling, you
have to work on kickboxing, Jujitsu,
and there's just not enough time in the
day and there's not enough time for your
body to heal. And that's where
it comes in. Doctor Field. Yeah.
It comes to the line, ie bay.
What do you think though,
with like, you know, Silva was
injured in there saying that maybe
the doctor that he was working with
had that has had a past of, you know,
over prescribing, you know, uh,
amounts of steroids or illegal,
you're saying maybe,
or he had,
no, he has, I saw something
the other day where, uh, a, uh,
what's his doctor's name and he's
like a Brazilian, um, uh, doctor that,
whatever his name is. But, uh, I guess in
the past, uh, this other fighter was like,
yeah, he, uh, I was,
it was approved to use this
kind of steroid or something
like that for an injury.
And he gave me too much.
And then I, uh, you know,
which caused me to be like seven
months of being penalized, you know,
out of the UFC,
and I forget this fighter's name,
but he says that's what's happening
is Silva Silva, he's like,
been fighting some 17. He's
never touched steroids. You know,
he's been working this injury
and it might just be that, right?
It could be. There's a lot
of, it could be that, but uh,
another issue was there was a,
um,
a TV show they did a long time
ago back from Anderson's house.
And,
uh,
one of the things that they saw in the
background was pen tips for a Norditrope
and it was on the shelf.
A very specific box that has pen tips
nor to trope in is a type of human growth
hormone pen. And you take this human
growth hormone injected in someone's body.
Um, and so that might not have been
his, so who knows, UFC fighter claim.
Some doctor who screwed up his TRT has
now victimized Anderson Silva. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Listen, you can't listen to these
guys though, because there's a lot. Yeah.
See Big Foot, you know, he,
he's blaming a doctor for him taking an
abnormally high dose of testosterone.
Maybe true may not be true,
but it's within his best interest
to say that the doctors at fault,
and it's not his fault.
The doctor said he was going to sue
him because the doctors like, you know,
you're,
you're lying.
I didn't do anything unethical
or outrageous to you and
everything you wanted me
to do, I did for you. Who the fuck
knows who's telling the truth? It's a,
it's totally a, he said she same
thing, it turns into a game,
but Anderson was coming back
from a broken leg and um,
he tested positive for
the way I understand it.
Metabolites, which means it was,
it was leaving his system is a very
trace amount. If that is the case,
it could very well be that he got on
some steroids so that he could heal up
quicker. Because what steroids do is
they allow you to recover quicker.
So if he's 39 years old and
he broke his fucking leg,
you're talking about a long ass period
of recovery or you take steroids and you
recover in nine months instead
of 15 months or you know,
fill in the blank with whatever,
the real numbers.
So that could be what was going on.
But the reality is it's illegal.
You can't do it if it takes you 15 months,
you use the excuse cannot be,
oh, I'm going to give you some illegal
drugs. So that you heal quicker. Um,
this is the only reason why you take
these drugs. Don't worry about it.
You'll be fine.
No,
you're never allowed to take steroids
because one of the things that happens
when he takes is it,
it creates permanent changes in your
muscles depending upon the steroid,
permanent changes,
permanent like your, your,
your muscle density and
your tenant strength and,
and various attributes of your muscles.
It's been proven that some of the
benefits of steroids continue permanently.
So it's not just when you're on them,
you're a fucking the hulk
because a lot of these guys,
especially back in the day when they
were fighting and pride like they,
I had ants in any way who was on the
podcast, who was a fighter from pride.
It was totally clean,
who said it was on his fucking contract
that they said on the contract,
we will not test you for steroids.
They set on the contract
encouraged guys to take steroids.
So a lot of guys took it,
but you get stronger than
you're supposed to be.
You're not really a person anymore.
It's like if you're a person, okay,
like let's imagine,
you know,
they're doing all these weird things
now with genetics where they're,
they're taking like a fucking a mouse
and a growing a human ear on its back and
then, you know, taking that human
man, inserting it in a person,
what do all these weird shit with people?
If they take Josh McDermitt and they add
one 10th of 1% rhino genes and all of a
sudden you're fucking running
through brick walls and ra,
are you even a person anymore?
If you get off that drug,
but you retain a fraction of that ability,
whatever the fraction
is you, you're, it's,
it's arguable that a
person who takes steroids,
especially prolonged steroid use over
a long career of fighting, you know,
you know, you've fought for 15 years, been
taking steroids for 15 years. You might,
you're not really technically the same
as you would ever be without those
steroids. Like you're, you're
another category. You're a,
Coca Cola has a certain amount
of ingredients. Okay, this
is a bad analogy, I know.
But if you look at the ingredients
of Coca Cola and you add Tequila,
that is not fucking cocacola anymore.
Now you have a new thing and
shit sandwich should be able to,
should you be able to serve that, that
Coca Cola Tequila out of a coke machine?
No, he should not because
people are looking for coke now.
Human beings very widely biologically,
so it's not the best analogy,
but the reality is,
especially as this is this whole steroid
out could epidemic is one thing we have
to recognize. The use of steroids
is less than a hundred years old,
less than a hundred years old
and steroids in athletics.
I mean I don't know what the fuck they
taking in the 1940s if they had anything
to complain, but they did. They did
take, came back then. I mean they did.
They most certainly did. Amphetamines
if always been an issue with baseball,
amphetamines and stimulants and things
that increase your ability to concentrate
and your, you know, your
ability to stay awake.
He's always been substances
that people have taken.
But the actual use of antibiotics,
steroids in human beings is
relatively recent in human history.
And I think that as time goes on,
they're going to create more and
more powerful and crazier shit.
And it's going to get to the point where
you're going to test negative because
you're not on it anymore.
But your body will forever be changed.
Like you'll girls would be in denial
about having a fake button. I'm like, God,
it's totally my butt. Well cause they can
take the fat, suck it out of your size,
pack it in your ass and it stays
in your ass. Now you know they,
it stays forever. When you gain
weight, you're asking its weight.
When you lose weight,
your ass loses weight,
but your ass will always have more fat
than it ever did before because you've
literally pack fat in there and people
can lie about it. And I got that scar.
I fell on a swinging when I was little.
You're going to have
men that are like that.
You're going to take a guy and
you're going to give him a shot.
And he's going to turn
into the fucking hulk,
and then that's shot's
going to wear off in,
his body's going to stay the same and it's
going to happen. It's going to happen.
There's,
they're on their way there.
There's all sorts of like this thing
that Hector lumbar got popped for today.
I've never even heard of this shit before.
They're calling a DMT,
which is obviously not dimethyltryptamine,
but it's, I'm going to try this.
What if it was yes,
so methyl testosterone,
deso desks, wo de soc psy, d e s o, x,
y to socksy methyl testosterone,
men destock,
socksy, detoxy, methy
testosterone, I dunno.
Whatever the fuck that is.
I never heard of it before.
And so it's apparently a designer,
anabolic steroids.
So what I think that means is that
these one of these steroids has been
concocted to get around the rules.
Like, um, you know, they had that shit.
The clear that Barry Bonds was on the
ball co scandal that was all about,
they devised a steroid that was very
similar in efficacy in the way it worked,
but not the same exact molecular
structure as like antibiotics,
doors that are common.
So they were able to put it on these guys.
Like it was like a lotion.
You would rub it on,
your body would fucking get crazy
and they would pass these tests.
You know this, the tests are getting way,
way more sophisticated. So who knows?
Lombard must've.
I mean it must've thought that he couldn't
get in trouble for this shit. I Dunno,
I don't understand it. Have you
ever tried a steroids, Josh? No.
I mean I've had like steroid
shots, cortisone shots,
stuff like that. But no dude,
they used to have the shit you could buy.
The strongest shit that I ever took.
You could buy, you could buy it in. Um,
you could buy it in like GNC
and it was called Mag 10.
It was ridiculous.
You take like 10 pills a day and you
would gain like I gained like 10 pounds of
muscle in like six weeks
of doing it too and this,
and this is how I know that it was a
total steroid because first of all,
now it's illegal.
You can't sell anymore.
But when I got off it and my Dick took
a vacation, it's like, see a dude,
like my testosterone just shut down.
It just stopped working and I was like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
Like I couldn't get it up like my dick
was broken for like two weeks up brief
man. But it's some shit
that you could just buy.
They used to be all these loopholes.
You can buy stuff at Gnc,
you could just buy these things
tribulus still no, that's legal. See,
those are very mild tribulus
and it's still fucked with me.
I remember taking that and then after
a couple of weeks getting kind of like
angry or that doesn't really make sense.
No, no. That's why were you taking it?
Very mild. I hang out with Joe Rogan. Man
Tribulus is just a route and it does,
it very mildly enhances your
body's production of testosterone.
There's another one called tongue
got Ali that has a similar effect.
That's also like a,
a plant based substance that mildly
enhances your body's ability to,
but it doesn't fuck with
the production of it.
The thing about steroids is
what happens is like you, you,
you take something and it just jacks your
body's levels of testosterone so then
your body's natural production
of testosterone shuts down.
And that's why like when I took that in
mag 10 stuff, like after I got off of it,
my body was like, yeah dude, I'm
not really feeling like fuck him.
We're just gonna.
We'll just take a little break here.
I mean it took two weeks to
get your wiener back, but
d two weeks it was really,
you know how long ago you were maybe,
I mean did you feel any other side effects
after going off of it or it felt like
how long did it take physically weaker
and, and then I lost some weight,
like a loss, like muscle mass. Like
you gained a certain amount of muscle,
but there was like a lot of these things
that you could just buy these shoes,
buy them at stores cause they
were like these loopholes. Like,
like you know how bath salts exists.
Do you know,
do you know the whole story behind it?
It exists for folks who don't know because
you would take something like crystal
Meth, which is an absolutely illegal
drug. But if you change just one compound,
one molecule of that compound,
just alter it slightly and then sell it.
No one can say it's illegal
because it's not illegal.
It's not the same thing anymore.
If meth is illegal and then
you just tweak it a little bit.
Like dimethyltryptamine was turned the,
this is the psychedelic drug was
made illegal in 1970 by the sweeping
psychedelic act of 1970 but they
missed five methoxy field trip to me,
which is actually stronger.
There's an end dimethyltryptamine and
then five methoxy dimethyltryptamine five
methoxy dive the trip to me and it's
like d dimethyltryptamine like an oxygen
molecule attached to
or something like that.
So it's just slightly different but legal.
But if you smoked it,
you would go to the center of the fucking
universe and converge with God in the
most epic journey of your life. I mean
it's like way stronger than mushrooms.
Yeah.
I mean you took a good
breakthrough dose of five Meo DMT,
he'll change you for the rest of your
fucking life. And that was legal.
And it was only legal because it
wasn't technically dimethyltryptamine,
which was illegal.
So that's what his bath salts thing is.
They alter the compound
slightly and then they sell it,
not for human consumption.
They say bath salts and then they sell
it at grocery stores or I mean, you know,
seven 11 so wherever they want to
send like gas stations mostly I think.
And they can get away with doing that
because it's not technically the same drug
and they just keep altering it,
keep tweaking it a little bit here and
tweaking it a little bit there with
varying results too,
which is really weird.
Like the difference between DMT and
five Meo DMT is profound in the effects.
Five meo is stronger,
but there's no visual experience.
The visual is just pure white and it's
like white molecules like fractal white
around you. It doesn't have
the visual effect of an end.
Dimethyltryptamine and dimethyltryptamine
it's just what you know. The,
the with Iowasca is based on, and
it's all, it's very hallucinogenic.
Like the things you see, the visuals
are spectacular, the colors are amazing.
All those things are missing from five
meo which is like kissing cousins to the
same drug. So it's, so that's,
I think one of the things that's wrong
with bass salts is like some of 'em,
you know,
you tweak it one way or another and
especially on different individuals have
different,
they have via biodiversity and the
way they respond to different drugs.
You have varying effects.
Like that fucking dude, wait,
that dude's face off grief.
Just like zombies.
We bring it back.
This zone.
Bees, how do you remember
all that Shit, man. Drugs.
Drugs helped me remember it.
I take Alpha brain.
That helps you remember you had to
have been really good in school.
I was terrible in school. That
makes no sense because you, you,
you capture so much information. You're
an encyclopedia of knowledge. Like,
I mean I was talking to someone the
other day, I don't remember who,
but I was just like, yeah, he like, he'll,
he'll start saying something and just
like 10 minutes later you're just like,
I don't,
I don't even remember what you said.
There was so much information you just
threw at me and it's not like you're like,
because for me, I'm always like, yeah.
So then there's this one drug and
it's like five and it's not something,
but anyway, no, you like, I dunno
when you learned about all this,
but I guarantee it was a while ago and
like you still can recall it like that
and that's,
but that's only certain Meyer that it's
only things that I'm interested in. See,
I have a photographic
memory for some things,
but for things that I don't give
a fuck about, there's no memory.
That's why he wasn't good in school.
He just didn't give it 100%.
I remember like teachers
that were annoying. Yeah.
I remember funny things
that happened in school.
I remember things that I learned
that I thought were, was fascinating,
but if I didn't care, like I, my brain
only works for Shit I care about.
If I, I'm like completely
reckless in that regard.
Like I didn't plan for the future at all.
Never graduated college,
never thought about it. Never like, man,
I need to figure out a way to get
a real job. Right? Nope. Nope.
Not gonna do it for,
from the jump.
Like I went to college for three years,
like completely just so that
people didn't think I was a loser.
This is the only reason why
I barely paid attention.
I went to Umass Boston
and just fucking half it.
I didn't even take my sats
because I'm one out of college.
I took a year off and I was like,
well, eventually I'll take my sats,
I'll go to school, get a degree.
But that was a bullshit in myself.
And then a year later I was like,
I gotta do something.
I can't keep telling people that I'm
eventually going to go back to college.
So I started going,
Umass Boston had this like continuing
education program where you didn't even
have to, um, have to, uh,
have sat scores and he just had to
have not failed high school, I guess.
I don't remember how it exactly when,
but I was wasting my time.
I just said it was just
going and half ass in it.
And then three years in, they, uh,
I think they told me I couldn't come
back because my grades were really bad.
So I,
I remember I,
I bullshitted and wrote this
really eloquent response and uh,
I wrote it all out and I was going to
send it in and then I read it and I was
like,
if I put half as much effort into school
as I did the bullshitting them with
this really eloquent letter that I'm
writing about, oh, I want to go to school,
then I feel like I got to stop.
Just stop.
I am not going to get a fucking
normal job. I need to, I,
my parents are completely
disappointed in me, but it's okay.
I'm already out of the house, so let's
just, let's just run with this. You know,
they didn't want me doing anything I
ever did it. So let me just keep going.
So the things that I'm interested in,
like back then,
if you asked me questions about taekwondo,
which is what I was
obsessed with back then,
I would be able to tell you everything
where it started, who created it,
who invented this technique,
who was first successful
with this technique when
they changed the variability
of a, the how you use your hips. One.
There's one style, it does it this way.
Another style does die the way this is,
this is the benefits of this
is the benefits of that.
And I would be able to rattle off anything
about things that I was interested in,
but it was,
it's like I have like a OCD,
like obsessive weird brain,
but it's not a good
brain for like lawn care.
Right. You know, it's not,
it's not a good brain for remembering to
pay your bills is not a good brain for
like if I had a job and you know,
you got to show effort to
be a part of this company.
This company is all about cooperation.
See that board.
We've got our tenants that we advised
by fucking checked out. Gone. Yup.
Second paragraph.
I'm already trying to figure out how to
make a live in delivering newspapers.
Right.
Don't have a boss or something
hilarious. I was horrible in school,
man. Yeah, of course you are.
That's why you were funny. But I would, I
would ace all my tests without studying.
Huh? Just cause I, I,
I learned by listening and so I just
keep my mouth shut a lot of times and I
just absorbed that way. And then, so
I listened to lectures or whatever.
And then in high school you,
most of your grade is your homework,
but I'm like fuck the homework and I'd
come in and ace my test and just barely
passed with a c, you know, because
I would at least get a little bit.
And so then in college was,
you know, they don't care
if you do your homework or not,
you don't get graded on that.
So I was like getting
great grades in college.
I just barely get by by just doing
the homework. We're up by the,
by ace and the test. You just
have a really good brain.
I mean, that's what it is.
Yeah. Your brain works. I slept all day.
I would stay up and watch the tonight
show with Jay or Johnny Carson and I'd
watch Letterman and then I would watch
whatever was after that and then go to
bed at like four in the morning,
wake up at six,
go to school for sleeping
every single class.
That's why we're happy to sit down
and be like this, you know? And then,
uh, somehow got a seat. Yeah, just got
CS. I got C's all through high school.
The problem with high school is that
it's being taught by people that are not
making any money. No one
gives a fuck about them. They,
you only hear about with
them when they make mistakes.
Nobody's praising teachers for being
amazing and being inspirational.
It's so rare that teachers get any props.
They,
they are not financially compensated.
Even though they have one of the most
important roles in a child's development,
they're not considered significant.
Yup.
It's a stupid fucking thing that we've
done. We've created these really arcane,
shitty, ineffective systems for
education and it's rare that you get one.
That's great. I mean, when you
find a good school district, man,
people fucking sell their house.
So we moved to these neighborhoods,
they do whatever.
They can start sign their kid up right
when they're born just to get into
kindergarten.
Yeah.
Do whatever they can to get their
kid into a good school system.
And then the argument of like, you
know, not paying the teachers as well,
we don't want to pay him a lot of money
and then attract the wrong kind of
people. Like, are you kidding me?
Is that mean man, it so stupid.
It's what, it's very aggravating. Yeah.
Several teachers in my family is very
frustrating to see the struggles that they
go through and not having enough money
in the budget to buy the fricking
materials they need to teach the kids
the curriculum. You know, it's, and,
and that's not just like
centralized to that school district.
It is like nationwide,
you know,
it's gotta be fun because kids like
to play. Like here's the thing,
one of the things that drives me fucking
bananas is this idea that kids that are
bored in class have a disease.
You the, he's got, oh, Eh,
a d h d o c d is,
he's got something. He's not sitting.
You're not supposed to sit. Okay.
Little kids are supposed to be playing
and there have low energy. Dude,
I have little kids and my six year old,
she's a fucking bundle of energy.
They literally will run around the house
screaming [inaudible] six and the four.
They get together and
they go and they just run.
It's like they have a flame inside them.
They need a burn off and you make a little
kid sit in a class and pay attention.
Pay Attention. Joshua,
Joshua up here on the board.
I want your eyes up here and you're like,
oh my God, I gotta get Outta here. Yeah,
your body's freaking out. Your body
is literally freaking out. You just,
you just want to get the fuck outta here.
Meanwhile,
you got a video game in your pocket,
you want to play or you got a fucking
comic book. You want to read it right?
Way more stimulating and
interesting in this horse shit.
This fucking ladies talking
to you in Spanish. We're in
America bench. Okay. Say,
no, no, no, no, no. I don't want to
hear it. I don't want to hear it.
I gotta get Outta here. And that's, that's
most kids through high school, you're,
you're fucking, whether it's math
or English or fucking history,
you don't want to be doing
that right then. And you know,
the idea is that they're
going to teach you discipline.
You're going to sit there and now
they're going to turn you into a god Damn
Zombie.
That's what they're gonna do.
They're going to turn you into a
cubicle Zombie. And if you let them,
they will do it. Or if you resist, you
can find your way out of the system.
But the idea that you're not
intelligent, unless you, you,
you follow this ridiculous curriculum
to turns you into a worker bee.
It's fucking stupid.
It's a stupid,
shitty plan that they've been
following for a long fucking time.
And it doesn't work on everybody.
You're different than me.
I'm different than you were
all were fucking different.
And every kid needs a different approach
to absorbing information and you're
going to have interest that I don't have.
You know,
like we were talking about video editing.
If I had to go to fucking school or I
had to become a video editor, I want,
I'm not interested in it. It's
not, I have no fascination.
Like if you had to become
a professional pool player,
you've know fascination with it. It's
like you, we all vary in our personality,
in our life experiences and in what we're
attracted to and some people are going
to be attracted to different things.
I believe that children should absolutely
learn the basic building blocks.
Every kid should learn how to write,
learn how to read.
You should learn how to count.
You should learn about the important
facets of history. Agreed. Everyone.
But the idea that every fucking kid
should follow the same curriculum the same
way.
And how come nobody ever takes kids that
are fucking antsy or the crack jokes
all the time. Nobody ever pulls
him aside and goes, hey man,
should be a fucking comic. Yeah.
Like you know, you could be a comic.
There's thousands of
them. Yeah. Like this is,
we're not talking about be the president
only going to be with to pull it.
When I grew up,
listen bitch,
there's one fucking president
won 350 million people.
One guy gets to be president. Good luck.
That's a shitty fucking job proposition.
Yeah,
you're your odds suck.
But the odds of being a comedian put
not bad. Right. You're actually funny.
You can, oh, you're at, listen, Johnny,
sit down. You're a fuck up. Okay.
Here's the good news. So it was bill
Cosby. So was Sam Kennison. That's right.
So it was Richard Pryor. So is Eddie
Murphy. They're all fuck ups. Okay.
Who the fuck ups or comics?
That's not all comics. You know,
I'm sure there's probably comics that
were like really studious and did great
and a good grades. A lot of
us were fuckups. That's right.
That's right. God dammit
Brian. He's right.
I guess
it's so funny how many,
like I always see the speeches
people put with your, uh,
from this podcast and like inspirational
videos and stuff like that.
You just had one the
other day on break.com.
I don't know if you know that where
they, somebody took a, you doing a, uh,
like kind of like a what you just did
but put it together with like the videos
and stuff. It's so amazing how many
people listen to those and, and uh, uh,
they're all over my Facebook
nowadays. Of Your, of your,
I hope they help. I do. I
hope they do. I don't mean it.
I don't do it cause I hope someone's
going to make a video out of it.
I do it because I'm frustrated.
I'm frustrated by people that I
know that are just living in hell.
I know too many people that just,
they,
there've been lied to and they don't
have anybody around them that tells them
any different. You don't have anybody
around them tells them this. And Man,
there's a lot of paths in this life.
There's a lot of people that
start their own businesses.
sell art or you know, or, or,
or become landscapers or do things
that they enjoy or you know,
become hunting guides or become,
you know,
someone who takes people on hiking tours.
It was a lot of fucking different things
to do in this life and everyone gets
lumped in to these same paths and they're
just shoving us in like fucking cattle
and to these,
these,
these packed in paths where everybody
wants to put that stupid hat on with the
tassels
paper that says, I'm not retarded.
It's, it's fucking crazy, man.
And you die just like everybody else dies.
You live and you die.
All you're supposed to be trying to do
is make enough money to get by and be
happy with what you're doing.
You're going to like different shit.
Yeah, it's ridiculous. I the
um, what are they called?
The counselors or whatever.
The woman told me I was too stupid to
go to college and then I shouldn't think
about going into the military
and that's what I'm saying,
which pissed me off because
they're, you know, that's stupid,
but a military or learning a trade, that's
what they told me and I learn a trade.
Okay, I need to learn a trade or, well,
neither of those interests me. Fuck,
you should learn how to kill people.
John, you're too stupid to go to college.
You should go kill,
sell insurance.
Be out shooting strangers.
Yeah. For Uncle Sam.
That's what they told me,
man.
I had horrible conversations with
high school guidance counselors.
They just work day. No hope.
There's no hope you won't.
You don't pay attention in school.
Nancy [inaudible] that was her name
was killing me. Nancy Klezmer. Well,
tell me about it. And so blinders,
she was a large woman. She, um,
I dunno when you're a kid, I don't think
you really know how old people are,
but she was probably mid to
late forties at the time.
So buried right next to John Candy.
Oh my God. When she'd have fat,
fuck the,
in the casket,
they put a suitcase full of snacks with
her extra support. She, you know, yeah.
It's like, but she, okay. So she tells
that to me. Who else did she tell that to?
It's hard, you know, and it's like, I,
I thankfully kind of
figured it out on my own,
but how many people don't really figure
it out that they just take that advice
and go, oh shit. Well, I guess, I guess
I should go learn to be a mechanic. Look,
the world needs mechanics.
I get,
but you can't just tell someone that's
their lot in life because you know
they're too stupid or something.
I mean there's some
mechanics are very brilliant.
I'm sure there's some stupid ones too.
Yeah.
And there's some mechanics that wanted
to be mechanics cause they love cars.
They enjoy it.
They get the thrill out of revving the
engines and figuring out how to make
things run better and figuring out how to,
I like working on cars,
but I don't want to do that for a living.
You know,
this is the idea that this
woman can do that too.
It's so disappointing that that person is,
if that was my fucking kid,
I would scream it. That lady,
if you came home and you know,
you told me that some lady told you you
are too stupid to go to college and you
had to be a mechanic or a
a fucking soldier, I would
scream at that lady. Yeah,
I would want her fired. I'm
like, you fucking monster.
Like you know you're planting seeds.
And these kids,
you're telling a child they're too dumb.
How smart are you that you got fat and
you're working as a guidance counselor?
You fucking dumb ass. You
Ain't thinking shit. I know
I, if I came home and told my
dad that he, you know, I didn't,
but I know if I did he'd
probably just would've been,
well what branch do you want to go into?
Like
that was your, that would have
been his response. You know,
that's probably why I didn't say anything.
Yeah.
My stepfather's thought for sure I was
going to be liquor fucking construction
worker or something. And then they have
a lot of faith in me. But when you,
you're coming home with all shit grades,
they knew I was good at drawing.
So like there's thoughts
that I would be an artist,
but then when I wasn't even into art and
once I start to get into martial arts,
it wasn't even an art anymore.
So this is like this,
this transitionary period between the
age of 15 to like 17 where there wasn't a
lot of shit going on in my life where
they were really worried about me.
Then I started winning all these
taekwondo tournament. It's now like, okay,
he's what? He's doing
something good, you know?
But even then they were worried
about that and they didn't want,
it was totally discouraging and they never
saw me fight. Once I probably fought,
I probably had a hundred amateur fights
and my parents ever saw one of them.
I won.
Yeah,
he got out of the art because you were
so good at it that at such a young age
that,
I mean like way better than most people.
I told you what happened. I had a really
shitty art teacher in high school,
asshole. He's just a
really angry, bitter guy.
He's just this pot belly dummy that
had given up on life. He was just,
this was this guy, this is my impression
and my art teacher in high school,
that's how he was.
That was his energy and he didn't like me.
He didn't like me because I was, I had,
I had a lot of energy. I was dynamic.
I wanted to just fucking
run through walls. I mean,
I was wired when I was a kid and
everything I would draw was like dragons,
eating villages and it was all like
fucking people running for their lives,
getting hacked to death by swords.
I was an angry kid and I
drew a lot of crazy shit.
Werewolves tearing apart rib cages, you
know. So that was what I drew, you know,
and he was really interested in you.
He's like, you've got to stop doing that.
But like this one I like,
I like that kind of stuff.
And I remember him saying this to me,
well, if you get a job as an illustrator,
you're going to perhaps have to draw
something that you don't enjoy a drawing.
Like maybe I'll have to do a diaper ad.
Okay,
so you're going to have to learn how to,
um, I remember like I'm out. That's it.
I'm not doing diaper ads. And
so I stopped drawing. Wow. Yeah,
I remember this guy was,
so, it was just so negative.
And influential because
enthusiasm is very influential,
but negativity is also influential.
And I,
he was connecting this world of failure
to this guy's path and I was like,
well I don't want to be an art teacher,
like this fucking shithead.
Just working with a bunch of people in
squashing their dreams because it wasn't
like I wasn't talented.
Like I still have those images and I've
put some of them up on Instagram and I
just should, I drew in 1983
okay. I was in high school.
I have some of these pictures so I know
I was talented and this guy just was a
douchebag and he just didn't,
he just gave me negative energy and so
I was very insecure and very young and
just dumb and you know, I
just, I just stayed away.
I didn't even take art my senior year in
high school and that was my whole path.
My whole path in life was I was going to
be a comic book illustrator, you know,
I was going to be like those guys
that did like the x men or you know,
an incredible hulk. That was my
idea. Like, I could do that like,
and I really could have done it,
but I was just so turned off by shitty
teachers just can't squash kids.
It's terrible. You can't do it. It's the
worst thing ever, man. And it's so common.
It's so common. Happens all the time.
It's Ari Shaffir has a joke about it.
He's got a joke about a, it's a
new, one of his new bits about, uh,
the notorious B I g you know,
when a biggie was young, like he,
he had uh,
this rap to all the teachers have told
me that you're going to grow up to be
shit.
You know,
I don't want to say any more because it's
a really funny joke and I want to give
any of the,
the joke away,
but he has this whole bit about these
teachers telling him that he wasn't going
to be shit right. That notorious
B I g was wasn't going to be shit.
It's ridiculous.
It's fucking common man.
Cause people don't have
vision and they don't have,
how could we have known Josh McDermitt
and that one day in Phoenix that you
would grow up to be the man who's on
my favorite show? How can we ever,
my second favorite show, I'm going to be
honest with you at the game number one,
but you guys are so strong, it's like one
a and one B. It's like right up there,
man.
The,
I've talked to a couple of their actors
and they're fans of our show just as
much as we're faced with. So like, you
know, good for you. Okay. It's okay man.
Like you're on one of the best shows ever.
In my opinion.
If it's a top 10 of my favorite
shows of all time, you're on it.
Who could have ever predicted that?
Top Five. Okay. What do you got?
Top five a surprise.
I'm not going to make your name 10
soprano's game of Thrones walking dead.
Dexter. First season stopper.
Southpark always. Yeah. What else?
Hmm? I'd have to go back. I was a,
if I was five. Yeah, that was five.
I'd have to go.
I have to go back through my entire
viewing history and think, Shit, oh,
homeland is pretty Gundam good.
Even that,
even that show took a dip. I think
it's pretty good. Uh, I don't remember.
I don't know what season
we're in now, but as I watched it all
on Amazon, so I don't know, last season,
the last season is not as good.
I don't know. I'm not current,
but dare you've watched like two
or three seasons. But I feel like,
like part of the second
season I'm going like,
I don't care what's going on.
Like I care about Saul,
but I don't care about Harry
Carey and bitch and uh, Brody.
But she fucks like a wild animal.
It was crazy ones. You know,
the crazy ones, they know how
to throw. Yeah, they trick you.
That's a good show though. It's not
as good as walking dead and it's not.
It's definitely not as good. Well,
it's good. It's great in moments,
in moments, it's fantastic.
But I call shows, man,
it's fucking hard keeping this show.
So solid episode after episode,
season after season,
it's gotta be one of the most difficult
things to do. It's tough. I like lost.
Like I remember, um, like the last
season of loss, I was totally done.
I was so done. I didn't even watch the
final episode. Yeah. I was like, fuck you.
I checked out. I was angry at it. That's
what I did with Dexter the last episode.
I didn't watch until recently,
uh,
watch the whole series and didn't
watch the last episode. I hurt so bad.
It ended better than you would imagine.
Uh,
but lost if you really real watch lost
and pay attention to what, you know,
you're supposed to pay attention to him,
it really changes the show.
It really makes it a lot better. Yeah.
That make, that kind of makes sense.
Just read something online
about one of the, uh,
one of the writers was at a dinner party
and they were talking to him about like
all the crazy shit that was inserted into
the show, the polar bears or whatever.
Like there's so many things that didn't
tie up at the end and he said, yeah,
we never had any intention of that
was just a can choose to define it.
It was just thrown literally throwing
in whatever. It's freaking me.
Blow out smoke monsters and shit. I
love that. I absolutely loved that.
There were some great
moments in that show.
There were some great moments in that
show, but it was rapidly inconsistent.
As was Dexter like Dexter, first
season, no one. Dexter went downhill.
It went downhill when that
dude stop lifting weights
because the first season he
looked like a killer.
He looked like a guy could grab people
and strangle them and beat their asses
and stab and then they
started getting like scrawny.
Was that cause cancer though?
Whatever. Excuses, excuses,
leukemia. Walk it up. Pussy.
I don't mean this. Ladies
and gentlemen. All right,
we should probably wrap this bitch up.
I think I ran at of time.
Josh motherfucking, mic dot. Dude.
Thanks for having me on. Thanks for,
thanks for being on and don't quit comedy.
You're too fucking funny.
Not quitting and I know it showed a nosy.
Got a nice cushy Gig on the walking dead.
You've got to show tonight.
Where can people see you doc?
I'm not promoting it.
I mean I don't know where it is. It's in
Long Beach, Long Beach. Just Google it.
You'll find them. It's probably at
the laugh factory in Long Beach.
Is that where it is or isn't?
It's not that.
It's like a one night show. So some
Weirdo spot. All right, my friend, uh,
you could follow Josh and
I found it on roadmaps. Ah,
you can follow Josh onto twitch.
Sure it is Josh McDermitt.
D. E. R. M. I. T. T. O. Yeah. Uh, and uh,
do you have a website? Uh, I
do. Josh mcdermitt.com. Oh, Sam,
Instagram and Facebook.
It's all just Josh McNary and watch
him on the motherfucking walking dead.
God Damn Son. Congratulations man. It
is really fucking cool to see you on TV.
Thanks dude. I haven't separated
you from the character though.
I'm enjoying your character,
which I thought was weird cause I know
you as a human being. Yeah. But you know,
I'm like, that's all good, Josh. Okay. But
it's all right. You know, I still like,
it doesn't take away from the enjoyment
at all, except you as this wacky,
fake scientists dude. But I still know
it's you. It's awesome. Uh, Brian,
anything coming up Friday, ice house
Friday at the Ice House. He fucks Judah.
Freelander my, I think might be doing it.
There be, be a part of that. Get some.
All right. You savages. All right. Much
love my friends. See you soon. Bye.
Right.